MonkaW!
Wurde übrigens gestern auf dem Fahrrad vom Auto umgefahren.
Falls jemand noch nicht mitgekriegt hat.
Ich hab's ja gestern auf Twitter gepostet.
Ich erzähl auch gleich nochmal was dazu.
Auf dem Fahrradweg.
Bäm!
Richtig MonkaS.
Man könnte...
Wo hab ich das, wo hab ich das?
Man könnte fast schon sagen MonkaSteer.
Ja, ich erzähl gleich noch was. Ich erzähl gleich noch was dazu.
Ich zeig euch auch mal ein Bild von...
Von Google Maps.
Von der Stelle. Das hat jetzt nichts damit zu tun.
Wollen wir hier was trinken, ja?
Ja, soweit geht's. Also...
Wie gesagt, ich hab ein bisschen...
Ja, ein bisschen am...
Am Arm.
Am Bein.
So ein bisschen abgeschürft und...
Mir tut's an der Hüfte weh, da wo ich draufgefallen bin.
Das war jetzt echt...
Also es ist, glaub ich...
Klimpflicher ausgegangen, als es hätte...
Also, als es anders...
Sagen wir mal so, hätte anders laufen können, ja?
Hätte anders laufen können.
Was ist passiert? Ich erzähl gleich ein bisschen was zu...
Wenn ich...
Wenn ein bisschen mehr Leute da sind.
Weil ich muss es wahrscheinlich eh noch fünfmal erzählen heute.
Könntest du als Z-Server-Meister...
Mal das Star Citizen Server Meshing anschauen?
Mir voran, ob es tatsächlich so besonders ist.
Auch wenn du nicht aus Game...
Also, wenn du mir irgendwie einen ordentlichen Link zum Artikel oder so gibst.
Server Meshing klingt jetzt ehrlich gesagt...
Nach einer ähnlichen Sache, wie das MMOs schon seit Jahren machen.
Dass das eben alles relativ...
Flüssige, flüssige Transitions für den Spieler...
Zwischen unterschiedlichen Servern, wo unterschiedliche Zonen drauflaufen.
Oder eventuell die gleiche Zone mehrfach läuft.
Je nachdem wie voll sie ist und sowas.
Klingt jetzt...
Ja, mir tut's immer noch...
Tut das Bein ein bisschen weh?
Also die Hüfte eigentlich gesagt.
Am Arm habe ich mir jetzt so ein Verband rum gemacht.
Weil natürlich...
Das genau an der Stelle ist...
Wo ich den Arm...
Auf den...
Auf die...
Auf die hier Unterlage lege.
Und...
Es sackt halt ein bisschen.
Ja, ich...
Wie gesagt, ich sag gleich was zu.
Warum es so...
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich such mir wahrscheinlich einen Anwalt am...
Ach, Entschädigung ist Blödsinn.
Ich will einfach nur, dass das Fahrrad repariert wird.
Und bezahlt wird.
Oder...
Keine Ahnung.
Ich hab mir das jetzt dazu überlegt.
Ich such mir einen Anwalt am Montag.
Der das oder jetzt.
Und...
Oder geb das denen.
Die sollen das machen.
Ich hab da keine Ahnung von.
Ich will mich damit auch nicht groß auseinandersetzen.
Sollen die das machen?
Und aus meiner Sicht ist das Ganze eh relativ...
Naja...
Klar.
Ich zeig's euch gleich.
Ich zeig's euch gleich auf Google Maps.
Wo ich umgefahren wurde.
Zum genauen Unfall her.
Zum genauen Unfall hergang werde ich nix sagen.
Weil man weiß ja nie was da vor...
Und gegen einen.
Für einen.
Oder gegen einen.
Verwendet werden kann.
Klar.
Aber ich kann euch die Stelle zeigen.
Also aus meiner Sicht ist es relativ klar.
Mit dem ich...
Auf dem Fahrradweg umgefahren wurde.
Gibt's da glaube ich nicht allzu viel.
Also...
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Aber die Sache ist halt die.
Ich will mein Fahrrad möglichst schnell wieder...
Wieder fit haben.
Deswegen ich lasse...
Ich ruf morgen einen Anwalt an.
Frag den wie man das macht.
Weil am liebsten würde ich morgen einfach das Fahrrad...
Zum...
Zur Werkstatt bringen.
Und sagen hier guck mal.
Rad eiert.
Macht mal please.
Entweder ausbeugen.
Oder macht mal am besten.
Weil ich muss ja nicht selbst bezahlen.
Macht mal am besten.
Gleich wenn ihr das für sinnvoll haltet.
Ein neues Rad rein.
Neuen Reifen vielleicht auch gleich drauf.
Ich weiß nicht ob der noch einen Schlag hat.
Macht ein neues Rad rein.
Und das einzige wo ich mir halt ein bisschen Gedanken mache ist.
Also.
Für mich sieht's so aus.
Als ist das vordere Rad ein bisschen verbogen.
Eventuell auch der Ring für die Scheibenbremse.
Scheibenbremse selbst.
Weiß ich nicht.
Glaube ich nicht.
Und.
Das Rad ausgetauscht werden.
Das.
Das Lenkerband.
Ist an der einen Seite aufgerissen.
Das muss man wahrscheinlich neu wickeln.
Das kostet auch nicht die Welt.
Und.
Der Rahmen.
Ist halt ein Carbon Rahmen.
Der hat ein paar Kratzer.
Und das ist halt so ein Ding.
Bei Carbon weißt du halt nie.
Ob der nur ein paar Kratzer hat.
Und das ist halt so ein Ding.
Weil das mal irgendwie ein bisschen.
Äh.
Bei Carbon verzieht sich ja meistens nichts.
Sondern es bricht halt.
Ja und.
Deswegen ist halt die Sache.
Man weiß halt nicht.
Deswegen das sollen die sich in der Werkstatt angucken.
Nicht dass der Rahmen wirklich irgendwelche Risse hat.
Und mir das Fahrrad auseinander bricht oder so dann demnächst.
Ich kann das nicht einschätzen.
Ich glaube das ja nicht.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Ich mein ich bin damit noch.
Heimgefahren danach.
Naja.
Der Restwert ist relativ easy, das Fahrrad ist erst im Monat alt, aber wir müssen hier keine Rechtsberatung im Twitch-Chat machen, deswegen suche ich mir einen Anwalt, der Verkehrsstells macht und dann sollen die das machen, das passt schon.
So ungefähr.
Ja, das will ich nicht, genau.
Oh, das ist mir aber zu high IQ für heute Morgen, ich mach mir das einmal auf, vielleicht gucken wir uns das demnächst an.
Ich lass gar nichts machen, ich suche mir morgen früh einen Anwalt, der sich mit sowas auskennt und der soll das machen bzw. mir sagen, was ich machen soll.
Ich mach gar nichts selbst.
Man muss wissen, wann man keine Ahnung hat und das Leute machen lassen, die hoffentlich Ahnung haben.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, lass doch mal kurz gucken, Hanau, Verkehrsrecht, Anwalt.
Was gibt es denn da so für Leute?
Wer hat denn gute Bewertungen?
Und was sucht man da überhaupt? Verkehrsrecht? Unfall? Ich habe keine Ahnung, aber was sucht man da am besten?
Top ADAC Anwalt, okay.
Ich weiß nicht, wenn man das in den Namen schreibt, klingt das irgendwie schon mal nicht so geil.
Hanau hat auch nur 4,4.
Was ist mit Google Maps los, Alter?
Alter, es ist ja voll.
Es ist ja voll.
Guck mal, das ist gar nicht so weit weg von mir.
Das ist aber eine schlechte Bewertung.
Recht am Platz 3,9, da gehe ich nicht hin.
Guck mal, 4,4.
Hat keine Web, doch hat eine Website.
Okay, zeigt mal her.
Anwalt für Verkehrsrecht in Hanau, Ansprechpartner bei Verkehrsunfällen.
Hatten sie einen Unfall?
Anwalt, Verkehrsrecht, Hanau, klingt ja schon.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo ich da hingehe.
Lass mal kurz, hat er Bewertungen?
Was hat er für Bewertungen? Reviews?
Anwalt liegt, ne, ich suche gerade, wo ich hingehen kann.
Superkanzler, sehr freundlich, kompetent.
Das ist ja alles drei Jahre her.
Furchtbar, vor fünf Jahren, na gut.
Da würde ich jetzt nicht mal allzu viel drauf geben.
Der Rest war eigentlich ausnahmslos positiv.
Joa, keine Ahnung, ich muss mal gucken, wo ich hingehe.
Das Schöne ist, das Schöne ist,
also zumindest, also erste Beratung ist ja meistens kostenlos.
Und nachdem das aus meiner Sicht eh relativ klar ist,
dass ich da absolut gar nichts für kann.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, wahrscheinlich gehe ich da gar nicht hin.
Ich weiß noch nicht, ich muss erst mal raussuchen.
Gibt ja, guckt mal hier, gibt ja jede Menge.
Ich muss die hier erst mal durchgucken,
wer da gute Bewertungen hat,
wer sich mit Verkehrs- und Unfallstells auskennt.
Und dann suche ich mal,
und dann suche ich mal irgendwas raus.
Arbeitsrecht.
Arbeitsrecht, Zivilrecht und was sonst noch?
Auch Verkehr?
Unsere Leistung.
Unfallregulierung, ja, das klingt doch auch nicht schlecht.
Kizim.
Ja, irgendeinen suche ich mir mal raus in Hanau.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass das so ein,
in Anführungszeichen, simpler Fall ist.
Das kann wahrscheinlich jeder.
Äh, nein, die Polizei war nicht da
und meine GoPro lief auf nicht,
aber ich habe mit meinem Handy Zeug aufgenommen.
Und als ich daheim war, habe ich Bilder,
habe ich Bilder gemacht.
Ja, klar, was soll ich machen?
Den ihr Fahrrad kaputt machen.
Das bringt es auch voll.
Ähm,
ich habe Bilder gemacht vom,
von der Straße,
von dem Fahrradweg,
von dem Auto,
inklusive Nummernschild.
Und als ich daheim war,
habe ich noch ein paar Bilder,
noch ein paar mehr Bilder von meinem Fahrrad gemacht.
Und von meinem Arm
und meinem Bein.
Das heißt,
ich glaube, den Rest lasse ich das echt.
Den Anwand regeln, weil, ganz ehrlich,
dann sollen die,
sollen die sich mit der Versicherung auseinandersetzen.
Dann sollen die auch sagen, was ich meine.
Also mein Wunsch wäre halt,
dass mein Fahrrad möglichst schnell wieder fit gemacht wird,
dass ich das benutzen kann.
Nein, nein. Danach, danach.
Anzeige macht null.
Anzeige ist raus.
Was passiert ist,
ich hatte gestern jemanden auf dem Fahrradweg umgefahren mit dem Auto.
Der war noch hier.
Max FPS.
Ich habe doch gestern hier ein Bild vom Arm noch gepostet.
Ich habe euch mal,
ich habe euch,
ich habe euch mal,
100 pro GoPro kannst du gar nicht machen,
wenn ich 3 Stunden fahre, dann hält die nicht durch.
Ich mache gar nichts.
Ich werde mir am Montag einen Anwalt suchen,
der sich damit auskennt.
Der soll mir sagen, was ich machen soll.
Wir brauchen keine Twitch Place Verkehrsrecht
und Twitch
Twitch berät mich,
das brauchen wir nicht.
Ich suche mir einen Anwalt, der sich damit auskennt, der soll das machen.
Da habe ich ja gepostet.
Ich habe mal darauf verzichtet,
mein Hintern zu leaken
auf Twitch.
Nur Arm leak.
Und es sieht am
Pobbers,
sieht es genau so aus, nur größer.
Also am Pobbers ist halt so der komplette,
komplette Pobbers
Übergang zum Oberschenkel.
Ja.
Ich wurde umgefahren gestern.
Mitten auf dem Fahrradweg.
Ich kann euch
auch gleich, ich zeige euch auch gleich auf Google
Google
Street View, wobei sollte ich das,
ist das taktisch geschickt, wenn ich es auf Google Street View
zeige? Keine Ahnung, ob man
da irgendwas, irgendwas
leakt, was ich nicht leaken sollte.
Na gut, warum eigentlich
nicht, ja? Warum
eigentlich nicht? Ich meine,
der Ort ist ja relativ
unstrittig, ne?
Beißt, danke für den Sub.
Wie weit das weg,
das ist nicht direkt bei mir in der Nähe.
Das ist schon ein bisschen weiter weg.
Ne, ne, ne, ne. Das ist schon ein bisschen weiter weg.
Ich zeige es euch, ich zeige es euch gleich.
Ich warte aber noch, bis der Stream
so richtig angelaufen ist, weil
ich muss es ja eh fünf mal erzählen,
wahrscheinlich. Wie sieht das Rad
aus? Ja, leider nicht ganz
nice. Das vordere Rad
ist verbogen, zumindest das,
was ich jetzt auf den ersten Blick gesehen habe.
Das vordere Rad ist verbogen
und
das Band am Lenker ist
gerissen und der Rahmen hat Kratzer.
Nachdem es ein Karbonrahmen
ist, keine Ahnung, hat es, klar hatte ich den Helm auf,
zum Glück. Aber ich habe, auf dem Kopf habe ich
nichts, habe ich nichts groß abgekriegt,
weil meine Brille und so war auch noch
aufgesteckt auf dem Helm danach und so,
überhaupt kein Ding.
Der Helm hat auch nichts abgekriegt.
Hat dich der Typ erkannt?
Nein.
Warum soll der mich erkannt haben? Ich meine, ein random
Dude auf dem Fahrradweg, da denkt man nicht bestimmt,
oh, das ist bestimmt, bestimmt
Wubblers, Alter. Das ist bestimmt
der Max von YouTube, den, den hab ich,
kenn ich, der kenn ich am, am,
wo auch immer dran. Nein,
der hat mich nicht erkannt.
Nee, nee.
Tü, tü, tü. Nee, nee, ist nix,
nix gewesen. Ja, ja.
Chat,
entspann euch, ich geh am Montag zum Anwalt,
der soll mir sagen, was ich machen soll.
Ich will die auch,
die, die anderen da auch nicht
irgendwie groß auf Schadensersatz
verklagen oder sowas. Also was für,
für, an meiner Person,
keine Ahnung. Soll man Fahrrad
wieder, sollen man Fahrrad bezahlen, ja?
Also die, die Reparatur bezahlen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Mich hat jemand umgefahren auf dem
Fahrradweg. Das ist passiert gestern.
Guck hier.
Ich hab nur den Arm mal geleakt, den Rest nicht.
Der Rest gibt's.
Ja.
Ich hab dann, wisst ihr,
die Kamera wird dann einfach noch ein bisschen weiter nach rechts
geschwenkt und dann, ja.
Aber nicht Onlyfans,
wenn schon Fansly, Alter.
Oder wie heißt das, wie heißt das andere?
Gibt doch noch so ein drittes,
was sich etabliert hat.
Vor ner Weile. Könnt ihr euch noch
dran erinnern? Vor 1, 2
Jahren hat Onlyfans doch gesagt,
sie wollen weg
von diesem Schmuddel-Image
und hin zu seriösem Content
wie beispielsweise Fitness und
sowas. Da hat man auch nie wieder was von
gehört, oder? Ich glaube,
die haben festgestellt, dass sie einfach
viel zu viel Geld mit
Onlyfans
ab 18 machen.
Die hätten ja
komplett ihr gesamtes Geschäftsmodell irgendwie
gekillt. Hätten die jetzt nur noch seriös
gemacht.
Weiß gar nicht, ich hab absolut keine Ahnung,
wie die damals auf diese glorreiche Idee
gekommen sind, ja.
Ist ein bisschen wie vor ein paar Jahren.
Vor ein paar Jahren haben sie ja auch
auf Pornhub
aufgeräumt. Da haben sie ja sogar den Account
von Tanzverbot damals gelöscht.
Leute, ihr wollt nicht wissen, was der hatte
auf...
Der hatte nen Pornhub-Account.
Wobei, so schlimm war das gar nicht.
Ich hab da mal rein
aus... Ja, zu Studienzwecken
reingeguckt bei Tanzverbot
auf Pornhub.
Eigentlich war da nix der Rede
wert so wirklich, aber der Account wurde auch gelöscht.
Genau, wir
programmieren den eigenen Fanschamp.
Ja, es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die will
man eigentlich gar nicht wissen unbedingt, ja.
Das hab ich mir dann auch gedacht danach.
Sind eigentlich... Eigentlich
hätt ich das gar nicht so genau wissen wollen.
Ja, die sind weg von mir.
Die sind ja auch echt bescheuert gewesen damit.
Es gab ja im Endeffekt
damals nur Tumblr.
So was das angeht. Ganz viel so...
Ja.
Ab 18 Content und dann haben sie irgendwann
gesagt, wir schmeißen die Leute jetzt raus und niemand
interessiert sich mehr für Tumblr.
Ja genau, stimmt. Ich erinnere mich. Das war
wegen Abrechnung
und sowas, ja.
Was aber allen auch bescheuert ist, weil
du kannst mit Kreditkarte nach wie vor auch bezahlen
auf Onlyfans.
Also, ne.
Und was da gibt
ist ja im Prinzip genau das gleiche.
Macht eigentlich gar keinen Unterschied.
Naja.
Die Logik muss man nicht immer ganz nachvollziehen.
Waren da eigentlich irgendwelche Reactions?
Ey, Leute.
Ich will mich da gar nicht so genau
mehr dran erinnern. Ich hab da einfach nur mal
Just for Fun nachgeguckt.
Es war nichts wildes ehrlich gesagt.
Es war nichts wildes.
Also, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern
auf Tanzverbot's
Pornhub-Account. Gab's im Endeffekt
Videos, wo er
nur mit einem
Handtuch bekleidet,
vor der Kamera saß
und erzählt hat,
was er sich jetzt für Porns
anguckt. Total unspektakulär.
Nichts wildes.
Also,
wenn man so will, dass der Account weg ist,
ist nicht weiter wild.
Aber ich fand's halt nur lustig,
dass Pornhub damals den Account gelöscht hat
für im Endeffekt nix.
Aber ja, das war wahrscheinlich auch im
Zuge dieser Kreditkarten-Sache.
Das war echt...
Ich weiß nicht,
was ihn da geritten hat,
sich einen Account zu machen, aber ey,
jeder, worauf er Bock hat.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass man damit was verdient hat.
Echt...
Bad Champ.
Hier ist Fuchs, danke für den Sub.
Und wer denn noch?
Ich muss mal kurz in meine Übersicht gucken.
Leute, gestern,
gestern Abend,
hab ich nochmal mich remote
auf die Arbeit eingeloggt,
weil ich was nachgucken wollte.
Ja, 5 Minuten, die hab ich auch nicht abgerechnet.
So einfach kann's gehen.
Wenn der Arbeitgeber sich normal verhält,
dann guckt man auch mal 10 oder 15 Minuten
Just for Fun abends nochmal nach.
Und...
Ich wollte nachgucken,
ob das
Blockchain-Download-Zeug
funktioniert hat.
Ich wollte mir Polygon
Snapshots runterladen.
Und...
Also, Polygon-Blockchain-
Snapshots runterladen.
Und das dauert immer eine ganze Weile,
weil das sind fast 3 Terabyte.
Und die werden dann noch entpackt.
Und da wollte ich nachgucken,
wie weit die Kiste ist.
Und ich hab gesehen, dass der bei 55%
abgebrochen ist beim Entpacken,
weil Checksum-Error.
Also, Download nochmal neu gestartet.
Gestern Abend
hab ich auch gedacht, fuck man,
warum ist das Zeug immer so Schrott alles?
Also eins hab ich jetzt echt gemerkt,
ich arbeite ja relativ viel
in meiner neuen Stelle
mit Cloud-Infrastruktur und auch
recht viel unterschiedliche Blockchain...
Ja, Infrastruktur kann man ja...
Das ist alles
unfertiger Schrott.
Das ist alles echt Alpha-Beta-Software.
Da funktioniert nix.
Und wenn du dann bei denen in die...
Also, die haben ja alle immer keine
Support-Möglichkeiten, logischerweise.
Das ist ja meistens nix superoffizielles.
Wo es dann irgendwie
eine Ansprechstelle gibt.
Die haben meistens Discord-Channel.
Die ganzen Blockchain-Dudes.
Und da ist immer die Hölle drin los.
Da kriegst du auch keinen Support für irgendwas.
Also, kannst du komplett knicken.
Das ist komplett
PP-Gar alles.
Gestern Google-Chrome-Update bekommen.
Sieht jetzt komisch aus. Echt? Ich hab noch kein
Chrome-Update.
Wir können aber gucken. Chrome-Update.
Was es da Neues gibt.
Fünf starke Verbesserungen für die Adresszeile.
Okay.
Hab ich das auch schon? Lass mal kurz gucken.
Ähm...
Chatge?
Wie macht man einen manuellen
Chrome-Update-Check?
Weiß das jemand?
Findest du die Idee hinter Blockchain
gut?
Weil Blockchain geht es ja nicht prinzipiell
immer um Geld.
Also, der Ansatz, ja.
Man könnte ja sogar so weitgehend
argumentieren, dass Git eines der
ersten Blockchains war.
Natürlich, nicht
ganz streng genommen. Du kannst es ja ohne Probleme
rewriten und manipulieren.
Also, manipulieren nicht, aber rewriten.
Aber es hat gewisse Züge davon.
Was Hilfe
über Chromium
ist aktuell. Okay, nö.
Bei mir sieht es immer noch genauso aus.
Alles fit? Naja.
Eigentlich nicht. Ich wurde gestern über
ein... Ich hatte gestern auf dem Fahrradweg
jemand umgefahren.
Aber ich wollte euch das ja zeigen.
Auf Google Maps.
Es kommt immer ein bisschen drauf an, was die da machen.
Ja. Aber ja.
Im Prinzip ist es das meistens.
Immer irgendwas geprooft
und gestaked
und was auch immer
gemacht werden muss.
Also, insofern...
Ich bin da im Detail auch nicht so richtig drin,
wie das jetzt im Detail bei den
unterschiedlichen Implementierungen funktioniert.
Aber in der Regel
läuft es schon irgendwo immer ein bisschen auf.
Ich will jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen, Energieverschwendung
drauf, aber man muss auf jeden Fall
einiges an Energie
reinstecken.
Wie hieß diese Blockchain nochmal mit Storage?
Wo sogar der Auer
mal mitgemacht hat.
Weiß das noch jemand?
Diese Storage
Blockchain.
Chia.
Genau. Wollte ich mal gucken.
Wie hat sich denn der Kurs so...
Ey, guck mal.
Über...
Oh.
Das war die Zeit,
wo das hier ein bisschen angesagt war.
Es ist halt einfach mal
komplett abgeschissen, Alter.
Guckt mal hier.
1.300
Bam.
20.
Not stonks.
Reverse stonks.
Mein Arm, by the way.
Monitor auf den Kopf stellen.
Ja, dann gehts hoch. Dann ist es zwar immer noch grün und rot.
Okay. Damit wir das jetzt
aus dem Weg haben, ich zeige euch mal, wo ich gestern umgefahren
wurde. Maps.
Google.
Meerhof See Alzenau.
Hier.
Google Street View.
Wurde ich gestern umgefahren.
Ich bin hier lang gefahren.
Und hier raus wurde ich umgefahren.
Wie gesagt,
zum genauen
Unfallhergang will ich mich nicht äußern.
Wer weiß, was da für oder
gegen einen verwendet werden kann,
aber ich finde, für mich ist es
relativ offensichtlich,
wenn du hier rausfährst, hast du das Schild für den...
Das ist ein Fahrradweg. Hast du das Schild
und du hast das Vorfahrt 8. Schild.
Also insofern, tja.
Ähm. Bam.
Da hab ich gelegen hier, gestern.
Nicht in your face,
aber in your Fahrrad.
So sah es da aus.
Also insofern,
hat es mich da ganz schön umgehauen.
Kann man...
Naja, naja.
Es hat schon eine Kurve.
Das Fahrrad, ne.
Das Vorderrad nicht mehr.
Der Rest ist, glaube ich, recht easy zu fixen,
aber das Vorderrad ist im Arsch.
Kannst du deinen Arm bewegen? Ja, ja, ja.
Ich kann Finger bewegen,
Arm bewegen. Also, was ich jetzt
hab, ich hab ein bisschen abgeschürft
am Arm, am Oberschenkel,
zum Porpoise hinter.
Zum Porpoise hinter.
Dann hab ich...
An der Hüfte tut es mir noch ein bisschen weh.
Wahrscheinlich kriegst du da einen blauen Fleck.
Und...
Tja. Ich merk's auf der anderen
Seite im Arm ein bisschen
hier oben am
Muskel. Wahrscheinlich bin ich da drauf.
Hab ich mich da abgestürzt.
Und ansonsten links und rechts
ein bisschen im Schienbein und in der Wade.
Ja, wahrscheinlich halt, weil ich hinten...
Also im Prinzip
sind die mir von der...
sind die mir von der Seite
reingefahren. Ich bin auf der
Motorhaube gelandet und dann bin ich runtergefallen.
Und...
Nicht die...
Das ist... Also keine Ahnung, ob es die
Speichen sind. Ich denke, es ist das
Rad, weil das Rad
eiert halt auch komplett.
Also ja, vielleicht sind es die
Speichen. Deswegen ist es jetzt ja auch schräg.
Also ehrlich
gesagt, um mich selbst,
mach ich mir jetzt in dem Fall gar nicht so viel Sorgen. Ich denke mal,
dass in zwei, drei Tagen ist das alles wieder gut.
Hoffe ich mal. Vielleicht... Je nachdem,
was der Anwalt sagt, geh ich vielleicht doch nochmal
zum Doktor und lass das fotografieren oder
aufnehmen oder was auch immer.
Aber...
Mir persönlich wäre es tatsächlich wichtiger,
dass mein
Rad relativ schnell gefixt wird.
Erstens, weil
nächste Woche vielleicht noch ein, zwei Tage
mal ganz gutes...
ganz gutes...
Jetzt kommt der Chat wieder hier!
Schmerzensgelb! Psychischer Schaden!
Ja.
Wer weiß. Muss man alles mal untersuchen lassen.
Aber zumindest
körperlich, muss ich sagen,
ich glaube nicht, dass das irgendwie
was Bleibendes ist. Man weiß es natürlich
nicht gerade an der Hüfte. Aber...
Das kann ich mir so aktuell
nicht vorstellen. Zumindest
haben die eine ganz schöne Delle
in der Motorhaube.
Nein, war ich nicht.
Aber wie gesagt, zu genaueren Sachen
mehr Details erzähl ich nicht.
Wie gesagt,
ganz schöne Beule in der Motorhaube.
Ja.
Und das Erste, fand ich auch eine geile Aussage.
Das Erste ist,
was...
was der Fahrer gesagt hat,
ist...
Er guckt eigentlich hauptsächlich nach rechts,
weil die meisten Fahrradfahrer von rechts kommen.
War halt kacke.
Ich kam halt von links.
Aber halt auf dem Fahrradweg, man!
Ja, ja, Chat.
Ich gehe am Montag zum Anwalt und dann...
Und dann lasse ich mir
von dem sagen, wie...
Vor allem...
Was? Das ist halt falsch. Man fährt auch auf dem Fahrradweg
rechte Seite.
Das ist ein Fahrradweg.
Man kann beide Richtungen drauf fahren.
Sieht man sogar auf dem Schild,
dass Fahrräder von beiden Richtungen kommen.
Ähm.
Ja, das habe ich gemerkt.
Das habe ich gemerkt.
Der Aufprall war weicher,
als ich mir das vorgestellt habe,
aber trotzdem hat es ein bisschen...
ging es ein bisschen auf die Hüfte, ja.
Wie gesagt, Max, guck, hier ist das Bild.
Äh.
Hier ist das Bild.
Vorfahrt achten, Fahrradweg von links
und rechts.
Übrigens, gegen dieses Schild hier oben ist anscheinend auch schon mal einer
dagegen gefahren.
Oder sie haben es zu fest getackert.
Also ich finde, aus meiner Sicht ist die...
Aus meiner Sicht ist die Lage
relativ klar, ja.
Also...
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht...
Ich habe ja auch noch gebremst, aber...
Ja, so sieht es aus.
In your face.
Der Fahrer war auf jeden Fall sehr
fertig mit den Nerven.
Ich muss übelst rumgeflucht haben,
als ich
auf dem Boden lag.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was ich gesagt habe,
aber ich glaube, ich habe die...
Ich habe die da irgendwie
ziemlich beleidigt, so.
Ich weiß nicht.
Oder auch nicht, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe mich ziemlich aufgeregt.
Wobei, glaube ich...
Nee, ich glaube, ich habe die gar nicht großartig beleidigt.
Ich glaube, ich habe nur irgendwas rumgeschrieben.
Was soll die Scheiße? Hier ist Fahrradweg
oder irgendwas in der Richtung.
Ich glaube, ich...
Ich kann mich nicht so richtig daran erinnern.
Ich glaube, ich habe gesagt, was soll die Scheiße? Hier ist Fahrradweg.
Irgendwie sowas.
Keck, keck, wait.
Genau. Was soll die Scheiße?
Hier ist Fahrradweg. Keck, wait.
Das wäre... So wie ich mich kenne, habe ich wahrscheinlich
auch ein Twitch-Emote hintendran gehängt.
Ja.
Monkastier, Alter, habe ich bestimmt gesagt.
Monkastier.
Wurde die Polizei hinzugezogen? Nee.
Fotos gemacht.
Vom Fahrradweg.
Vom Auto.
Ähm...
Kontaktdaten aufgeschrieben.
Auto fotografiert mit Nummernschild.
Ja, wie gesagt,
aus meiner Sicht ist es auch sehr eindeutig,
wer es da verkackt hat.
Ich meine, du hast als Autofahrer
ja eigentlich prinzipiell immer gelitten.
Egal, was ist, wenn du einen Fahrradfahrer umfährst.
Aber in dem Fall ist, glaube ich, echt
ziemlich eindeutig.
Eindeutig, ja.
Was ich witzig fand, guckt mal hier auf Twitter.
Die meisten Leute
haben ja geschrieben,
die meisten Leute haben ja geschrieben,
da musste ich auch keck waiten und keck w'n,
als ich das gelesen hab.
Die meisten Leute haben ja nur geschrieben, ey, alles gut und so.
Und dann kamen schon manche,
manche kamen wieder an, so, ich kenne die ganzen
scheiß Fahrradfahrer, ihr seid selber schuld
und sowas.
Aber irgendwo...
Sorry, aber das glaube ich tatsächlich.
Ich weiß, wie Fahrradfahrer drauf sind.
Okay, also, der hatte schon mal
ein Problem mit Fahrradfahrern, das heißt,
prinzipiell, pauschal,
bei allen ist das alles immer fake.
Was ist denn das eigentlich für einer?
Lass mal kurz auf sein Profil gucken. Wobei, ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Auf random Profile zu gehen
ist eigentlich echt immer problematisch, ja.
Oh.
Das ist...
Oh Gott, da will ich gar nicht weiter scrollen.
Wer weiß, was da jetzt alles kommt, ja.
Ich lass mal lieber bleiben.
Ja.
Der Name allein schon, ja.
Ich scroll mal lieber nicht weiter.
Wer weiß, was da jetzt gleich noch alles kommt, ja.
Das ist wahrscheinlich reiner Fake.
Wahrscheinlich ist das der eigentliche Fake,
der Account, den er nur gemacht hat,
um quasi so diese eine Sache
überall drunter zu pasten.
Ich hab ein PayPal-Spendenkonto.
Aber ich will keine spenden.
Entweder PrimeSub,
oder du kannst auch auf YouTube
subscribe. Oder du kannst einfach so zugucken.
Mach einfach
PrimeSub, wenn du welche hast. Also ganz ehrlich,
ich bin da auch nicht wirklich
drauf angewiesen. Ich find's natürlich nice, dass man
hier auf Twitch und auf YouTube bisschen was nebenbei
verdienen kann. An mir ist es lieber, die Leute
kommen ins Stream und freuen sich, dass
das Stream ist.
Auch wenn ich manchmal natürlich ein bisschen Sellout mache.
Also wer noch PrimeSub übrig hat, ne, ich hab natürlich
nix dagegen.
Aber ist schön, dass ihr am Start seid.
Das reicht mir ja alles schon.
Ich habe den Eindruck, Leute,
dass es gefährlich ist,
dort zu arbeiten, wo ich jetzt
arbeite, weil
mein Chef hat mir letztens
erzählt, der hatte auch einen Autounfall vor ein paar
Wochen. Aber eher im Auto
versus Auto. Nicht wie
ich. Fahrrad versus Auto.
Also anscheinend scheint der Arbeitgeber ein
erhöhtes Risiko zu haben, dass Leute, die dort
im Linux-Team arbeiten,
Unfälle abbekommen.
Ich hatte mein Leben lang
noch keinen richtigen Unverkehr, also
Unfall schon, aber noch keinen Verkehrsunfall.
Und ich hatte diesmal auch übelst Glück.
Es ist ja nix Großartiges, zumindest an mir,
so wie es jetzt aussieht,
passiert. Ich meine, das kann
auch mal ganz schnell nach hinten losgehen.
Ja, stimmt, vielleicht liegt das daran.
Die wollen testen, ob ihre Workflows
funktionieren.
Vielleicht hat hier jemand zufällig
eine Ahnung. Ich kriege beim Öffnen von
QAndA folgende Message. OpenMem failed.
Ich habe keine
Anhaltspunkte. Ich würde
sagen, die Anwendung ist kacke
programmiert. Das liegt nicht an deinem Rechner.
Die Anwendung ist scheiße. Die macht
Zeug, was nicht funktionieren sollte.
Macht Zeug, was nicht funktioniert.
OpenMem failed. Es kann auch sein,
dass er versucht, das zu
starten mit GPU Acceleration
und das nicht funktioniert wegen deinem Grafikkartentreiber
und so. Qt ist da...
Qt versucht beim Starten raus
zu finden, was das beste
Render-Backend ist
für deine Anwendung. Du kannst
mit Kommando-Zeilen-Parameter
forcen, dass die
Qt-Anwendung in Software-Rendering
gestartet wird. Irgendwie. Fragt mich
nicht mehr aus dem Kopf, wie das funktioniert.
Und vielleicht geht es mit Software-Rendering.
Weil Qt hat
unterschiedlichste Möglichkeiten.
Qt kann rendern per, ich glaube, Valken
mittlerweile, per OpenGL,
per Direct3D,
oder Direct2D ist es in dem Fall.
Also DirectX.
Es kann rendern per...
per...
Ich habe vergessen, wie das heißt.
Per OpenGL zu DirectX
Translation Layer
und es kann Software-Rendern.
Du musst mal gucken,
ob du Software-Rendering
einschalten kannst. Dann ist die Anwendung
vielleicht, was Animationen angeht, ein bisschen
ruckelig. Aber das ist nicht so schlimm.
Da kannst du gucken, ob es dir zumindest öffnet.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es an deinem Rechner irgendwie liegt,
dass sich eine Qt-Anwendung nicht starten lässt.
Es liegt an der Anwendung.
Was können wir uns denn... Ach nee!
Chat-Gil. Ha! Ganz wichtig.
Wir müssen uns ja
Weekly angucken.
Was ist Rendering?
Wie die
Bildinformationen auf deinem
Bildschirm kommen.
Also klassischerweise, ganz früher,
war Rendering ungefähr so.
Das nehme ich jetzt mal als Beispiel,
weil das...
Ich kenne die genaue
Definition nicht. Also ich würde sagen,
zu Rendering gehört
der Weg, wie halt
die Grafikinformationen
sowohl
aufbereitet werden, in ein
darstellbares Format
für deine Grafikkarte
und letztendlich
die Grafikkarte, die das Ganze dann auf dem
Bildschirm anzeigt.
Also,
du hast vielleicht in deinem Spiel
irgendwelche 3D-Objekte
und das muss ja alles berechnet werden, letztendlich
in ein Bild, sagen wir
920x1080
in RGB.
Also quasi irgendwelche 3D-
abstrakte 3D-Kulisse
muss umgewandelt werden
in ein flaches Pixelbild.
Und das ist das, was ich als
Rendern bezeichnen würde.
Also du hast quasi
deinen internen Anwendungs-State, der umgewandelt
werden muss in ein Pixelbild
und dann, und so lief das
früher, und dann wurde das quasi
per
zu DOS-Zeiten und Windows-3.1-Zeiten
lief das noch so, und dann wurde das
quasi direkt in den Grafikkartenspeicher
kopiert
und die Grafikkarte hat es dann
beim nächsten Refresh auf dem Bildschirm angezeigt.
So, das würde ich sagen,
das ist Rendern, oder?
So mal aus dem Ärmel geschüttelt,
irgendwas.
Irgendwann haben sie festgestellt,
das ist keine allzu gute Idee,
direkt aus dem Grafikkartenspeicher
aufs Display zu rendern
und daraufhin hat man dann sowas gemacht
wie Double-Buffer.
Man hat einen
Speicher gehabt,
wo das Bild reingerendert wird
und einen Speicher gehabt
für das Bild, was auf dem Monitor angezeigt
wird und
man hat immer in den Back-Buffer
gerendert, also der der
nicht angezeigt wird
und dann hat man den Back-Buffer,
wenn er fertig war, rüberkopiert
in den Speicher, was auf dem
Bild angezeigt wird. Hat dazu geführt,
dass es halt viel weniger flimmert
und
dass alles insgesamt
halt
weniger hakelig aussieht.
Das war so eines der ersten Sachen,
die sie sich ausgedacht haben.
Mittlerweile ist ja mit
direktem Grafikkarten-RAM-Access
eh nix mehr.
Das heißt, heute musst du durch sowas wie
OpenGL und DirectX gehen.
Oder Vulkan oder
sonst was, irgendwas, was dein Grafikkarten-Treiber kann.
Ja, das ist was
komplett anderes.
Das würde ich...
Server-seitiges Rendering
hat nichts damit zu tun, wie man das
sich hier vorstellt mit dem...
Bei Rendering im
Web-Anwendungskontext wird
ja eigentlich meistens davon gesprochen,
dass man JavaScript-State umwandelt
in HTML.
Und das HTML muss dann erst noch
vom Client, also
vom Browser wirklich gerendert
werden zu was, was
auf dem Display angezeigt werden kann.
Also wenn du es so willst, gibt es eigentlich zwei
Rendering-Steps, wobei der eine streng genommen
gar kein Rendering ist, nämlich das
JavaScript umwandeln in
HTML. Das HTML
wird dann vom Browser gerendert
in ein Format,
was deine Grafikkarte anzeigen kann.
Ich glaube, dass
Server-seitiges und Client-seitiges Rendering
zu vermischen, was Web-Anwendungen angeht
mit irgendwelchen Spielen,
verwirrt eigentlich nur, weil es schon mal
ziemlich...
unterschiedliche Sachen sind.
Ja, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Qt-Installation kaputt.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass es
an deinem Rechner liegt.
LässigerLord, dankeschön für den Sub.
Relaxing
Music
From Super Mario Series haben wir heute als Playlist.
Äußerst
Relaxing. Und was
ist das, wenn man YouTube-Videos rendert, um sie
hochladen zu können? Da sieht man mal, in wie
viel unterschiedlichen Kontexten
das Wort rendert benutzt
wird. Das hat auch nichts
mit dem klassischen rendern, also
quasi Bild in
Pixel so weit aufbereiten, dass du es
anzeigen kannst, zu tun. Also
mit YouTube-Videos rendern ist
gemeint, dass das Source-Format
von deinem Video
umgewandelt wird in ein Format, das
YouTube mag
beziehungsweise das Browser anzeigen
können. Kann ich dir
zeigen? Nehmen wir mal das Video hier.
Gehen wir rüber in die 4M.
Also stell dir vor, du lädst auf YouTube
jetzt ein Video hoch. Oh guck mal,
es gibt ein neues Release. Interessant.
Hippie. Find me later.
Ne, das ist höchstwahrscheinlich nicht das, was
die Anwendung benutzt.
Die bringen ja meistens
CuteSaps mit. Ne, dann
bringt dir das nichts, da hast du recht.
So, guck mal hier.
YouTube
DLP
Minus F
So, und da siehst du
die ganzen Form... Es ist Minus
Groß F.
Da siehst du die ganzen Formate,
die YouTube anbietet hier.
So, und jetzt stell dir mal vor, du lädst
ein Video hoch, MPEG2
in einem
MKV-Container.
Das kann kein Browser anzeigen.
Deswegen wandelt YouTube
dein Video, falls das das überhaupt
supportet, aber ich denke mal schon,
weil alte Aufnahmen, alte
Fernsehaufnahmen sind oftmals MPEG
2 TS.
Und dann wandelt YouTube das Video
um in ein Format, was Browser
verstehen. Ja?
Zum Beispiel... Ja, das ist relativ
relativ modern hier.
MP4 ist
bescheuert. MP4 ist eigentlich nur der Container.
Also eigentlich muss man das hier gucken.
VP9 und AVC1, das ist ja der eigentliche
Codec.
Und das ist im Fall
von YouTube-Rendern.
Die wandeln dein Source-Video-Material
egal in welchem Format
es ist, um in eines
dieser Formate hier, wo YouTube
denkt, dass sie besonders gut im Browser
funktionieren. Und wenn ihr einen
Browser habt, der beispielsweise
VP9 kann, was
glaube ich, alle sind
außer Safari.
Da bin ich mir aber gar nicht so sicher,
ob es nicht Safari auch noch
kann, nicht kann mittlerweile.
Also du musst eigentlich standardmäßig davon
ausgehen, dass Safari irgendwas nicht kann, wenn es
relativ neu ist.
Safari kann es natürlich nicht.
Aber Safari und
iOS kann es zumindest
zumindest
teilweise. Ja?
Oh doch, hier, Moment, das ist AV1
nur, ihr habt mich sogar verguckt.
Ich will ja
VP9 gucken.
Okay, aber Safari und
iOS kann es auch nur teilweise.
Das ist halt das Ding, warum ich
manchmal sage, Safari,
gerade der iOS-Safari
ist der neue Internet-Explorer,
was moderne Technologien angeht.
Sie haben die letzten, aber wirklich
auch nur die letzten 1, 2,
ja, das war es eigentlich, Jahre,
wieder ein bisschen aufgeholt, weil
aufgefallen ist, so langsam wird es richtig
beschissen.
Aber Safari, es kommt
doch eher auf die Grafikkarte an, ne,
das kommt sicherlich auch auf die Grafikkarte
an, aber der Browser muss es erstmal unterstützen.
Und Safari und iOS
kann es anscheinend nur unter bestimmten Bedingungen.
Okay, guck, guck, Safari
kann es nur
für WebRTC-Verbindungen,
was auch gut ist,
jetzt konnten sie auch eine Weile nicht, weil
VP8 ist, glaube ich,
der Standard für WebRTC-Verbindungen,
die sollten alle Clients unterstützen.
Es ist halt schon bitter, ne, wenn du dir hier überlegst,
dass die anderen
Browser das teilweise, guck mal,
Firefox 23, ihr müsst euch das mal überlegen,
Firefox 28
hatte das erste
Mal Support dafür, 28.
Das ist von 2014,
ja, und Safari, iOS hat es bis heute
nicht richtig.
Und das hier
kann Safari, glaube ich, auch nur mit
Feature-Flag, ja, das kann
nur auf, kann nur
iPhone 15 Pro Max
or later, kannst du also auch knicken.
Es ist in gewisser Weise
verständlich, ja, dass sie
sagen, hey, wir wollen da keine Software, kein
Software-Renderer mit bereitstellen, weil das einfach zu viel
Akku frisst. Also trotzdem
scheiße, ja. Es muss ja, es muss ja
an beide, es muss ja beidseitig
unterstützt werden, also der Browser muss das unterstützen
und dann ist es zusätzlich noch
sehr sinnvoll, wenn es deine Grafikkarte
oder ein Hardware-Decoder kann,
dass es eben nicht so sehr auf die CPU geht und damit
auf die Akkuleistung.
Aber man sieht's hier schon, die sind schon echt ganz schön hinten
dran. Firefox kann's schon
deutlich länger als Chrome, aber Firefox ist, was
Video-Formate angeht, eh meistens recht
gut dabei.
So sieht's aus.
Da war aber einer super kreativ, oder?
Ich sag doch,
ich sag nicht, dass es IE ist, ich sag,
dass es der neue IE ist.
Wenn's einen Browser gibt,
bei aktuellen Entwicklungen, der bei
vielen Web-Standards
und auch bei vielen Sachen, die schon lange etabliert
sind, nicht richtig mitmacht oder
wahnsinnig hinten dran ist, dann ist es von den
drei eindeutig Safari.
Und die machen
ja auch manchmal so ähnliche Sachen wie
der IE, eigene Dinge,
obwohl es dafür Standards gibt.
Also, ich finde, der Vergleich ist gar nicht
so weit hergeholt.
Es ist noch nicht ganz so krass wie mit dem IE,
das stimmt, aber ich glaube, es muss
auch nicht erst Internet Explorer,
das Internet Explorer Niveau erreichen,
um es mit Internet Explorer mal
zu vergleichen. Also Safari ist,
wenn du die aktuellen Browser vergleichst,
eindeutig der technisch
rückständigste.
Und oftmals sogar auch noch die
iOS-Version. Die Desktop-Version kann
ja manche Sachen wie die iOS, umgedreht bestimmt
auch, aber es ist halt kacke.
Und das Problem ist daran,
dass du nicht mal sagen kannst, ach, guck mal,
ich benutze jetzt einfach
Chrome oder Firefox auf iOS-Geräten,
dann geht das ja alles,
denn, wie ihr sicherlich
schon mitbekommen habt, gibt es kein
Chrome und Firefox
auf iOS.
Und dementsprechend könnt ihr
auch kein Chrome und Firefox benutzen
für mehr Features, die der Safari nicht kann.
Der Internet Explorer Nachfolger ist
Edge, das ist richtig, aber Edge ist kein Problem,
weil Edge auf Chrome basiert.
Gut, es gibt irgendwelche
Leute, die müssen
Edge für
iOS rausbringen,
falls es das gibt, aber das ist dann auch Safari.
Nein.
Safari benutzt WebKit
und WebKit
ist, glaube
ich, das, was vor
Urzeiten Chrome auch mal
verwendet hat. Aber ich bin mir
da nicht sicher aus dem Kopf.
Chat, stimmt das? War Chrome
nicht auch ganz am Anfang mal WebKit?
Ja, genau, so war
das. Genau, Chrome ist aus WebKit.
Aber die sind schon lange
nicht mehr
reines WebKit.
Safari wahrscheinlich am längsten.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Dass es einen Browser geben wird, der immer top aktuell
alle neuen Standards und Features
supportet, aber muss man sagen,
Chrome und Firefox sind da schon echt gut dabei.
Die unterstützen ja teilweise Features,
die für die noch gar kein richtiger Standard
oder fertiger Standard
und Implementierungsspezifikation
und alles existieren.
Die sind ja jetzt schon dabei, WebGPU
und sowas einzubauen. Bis wir das
mal in Safari sehen, dauert wahrscheinlich noch
Jahrzehnte. Nicht, dass ich jetzt Mist erzähle
und das ist eines der wenigen Sachen, das Safari tatsächlich
kann.
Gucken wir mal.
Okay, natürlich nicht.
Das ist Firefox
Feature Flag.
Safari, Safari
und Firefox.
Wobei ich Safari
ungern als, wobei
also ich klassifiziere
Safari ungern als gängigen Browser.
Die Realität sagt aber,
Safari ist ein gängiger Browser.
Weil iOS Geräte
sehr verbreitet sind und
Mac Anzahl halt auch steigt.
Insofern.
Ja, Chrome und
Firefox auf iOS sind Safari
anders verpackt.
Wobei ich gelesen habe, dass
Apple das demnächst erlauben möchte.
Eine andere Browser
neben Safari.
Frage ist, ob das schon passiert ist oder nicht.
So wie ich Apple kenne wahrscheinlich nicht.
Die werden das rauszögern, bis es nicht mehr anders geht.
Aber da gab es mal vor einem Jahr
oder so News drüber, dass demnächst
3rd Party quasi
Browser Engines auf iOS erlaubt sind.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass es nicht gehen würde.
Ja,
da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass es nicht gehen würde.
Selbstverständlich könntest du Firefox und Chrome
exportieren auf iOS.
Aber Apple will das nicht.
Und dementsprechend kannst du keine App Store Distribution machen
und das ist für'n Arsch.
Also in einem der Guidelines
von Apple steht halt drinnen, als Browser Engine
muss Safari verwendet werden.
Ja.
Gucken wir mal, ob es dazu irgendwas gibt.
Okay, letzte, Anfang des Jahres
gab es nen
New iPhone Browsers on the way without
Webkit. Ja, schön, aber
ich glaube da gibt's noch nix.
Letzte News sind, sagen wir mal
ein Dreivierteljahr her.
Wisst ihr,
ich hab ja was so rechtliche Sachen angeht
nicht viel planen.
Man könnte jetzt sagen, das ist ja ähnlich
wie damals Microsoft Internet Explorer
gebundelt mit Windows.
Der Unterschied ist nur,
dass
damals ganz klar war,
dass es auf dem Desktop
eben neben Windows
so gut wie nichts gab.
Apple wird wahrscheinlich
argumentieren und sagen, der Markt ist ja nicht
iOS, sondern Smartphone
und bei Smartphone gibt es aber
genug Konkurrenz und dementsprechend
haben wir da keine marktbeherrschende Stellung
und wir müssen das auch nicht machen.
Würde ich jetzt mal vermuten. Windows war damals
relativ unstrittig, das war irgendwie keine Ahnung.
98% aller Desktop Computer
hatten Windows, das war relativ klar
zu sagen, ey
Windows gebundelt mit Internet Explorer heißt
marktbeherrschende Stellung, was auch immer.
Bei Smartphones ist das nicht zwangsläufig so.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass
Apple da Bock drauf hat und
so wie es aussieht, tut sich da
auch nicht allzu viel. Guck, es gibt
im Februar
gab es immer mal wieder
Meldungen hier, die haben
im Prinzip wieder alle
voneinander abgeschrieben, weil das kam auch
alles vor dem gleichen Tag.
So sieht es aus.
Chatgis.
Lass uns mal kurz schauen, was trendet
auf Shithub.
Read it later solution for people
who like reading.
Sowas finde ich ganz praktisch.
Allerdings eher
als, sagen wir mal, etwas schlauere
Bookmarkverwaltung
mag ich sowas.
Ich benutze ja öfters
Pocket von
Firefoam, aber so ganz
glücklich bin ich damit auch nicht.
Weil es halt ein Cloud Service ist.
Das einzig coole daran ist,
du kannst es halt automatisch
sünken zwischen deinem Desktop
Browser und
deinem Handy.
Ich benutze Pocket so gut wie nie
zum Lesen, ich benutze es nur zum
Suchen und zum Links Speichern.
So, das finde ich mal
ganz interessant, was das hier.
Omnivore, das heißt
Allesfresser, oder? Das ist doch was
die Veganer immer verwenden.
Allesfresser, ja.
Okay, wie, Sign it up.
Ich will es selbst hosten.
Docker Compose, okay.
Native
iOS App. Wenn es eine
Native iOS App ist,
wo ist der
Store Link? Ah, tatsächlich.
Nice.
Sogar im Store. Nicht schlecht.
Nicht schlecht.
Wann gab es die erste Version?
Ich kenne das noch gar nicht, kann doch nicht so alt sein, oder?
Ah, doch.
2021,
ja, wobei, so alt ist es nicht.
Eigentlich eine coole Sache.
Müssen wir uns mal angucken,
was das kann.
Also wichtig für mich
ist halt, das ist im Prinzip
dann quasi eine Linksammlung,
Sync Service,
wenn man es so will.
Was für mich wichtig ist, ist nicht so, wie cool man da drin
lesen kann, sondern dass die Suche ordentlich funktioniert.
Das finde ich
ganz...
Bookmark Sync ist cool,
aber viel cooler ist Bookmark Sync
inklusive Suchmöglichkeiten
über die Sachen, die man gebookmarkt hat,
zum Zeitpunkt des Bookmarkens.
Das muss ich mir mal angucken. Das ist interessant.
Das muss ich mal ausprobieren.
Wie hostet man das?
Getting started.
Oh, guck mal, gibt es gerade
Deutscher Guide.
Speichern, lesen, organisieren.
Guck mal, es gibt Firefox, Edge, Chrome.
Cool.
Finde ich sehr nice.
Viel
interessanter ist,
wie hostet man das gescheit selbst?
Ich habe eh den Docker Compose gesehen.
Postgres?
Ja gut, warum nicht?
API Backend?
Web?
Ja.
Könnte man tatsächlich mal ausprobieren.
Wie syncht ihr denn
eure Bilder und Videos vom Handy zum Nasterheim?
Ehrlich gesagt gar nicht.
Ich mache einfach alle paar Monaten
ein Backup von meinem Smartphone.
Also von den
Data Folder von meinem Smartphone
und lege das verschlüsselt auf mein NAS fertig.
Wenn man natürlich jetzt öfters mal
mit der Familie am Fernseher
irgendwelche Bilder angucken will, ist das natürlich
nichts.
Gehen tut es bestimmt? Ich habe keine Ahnung wie.
Man sollte nicht anfangen, die Hersteller
Cloud zu verwenden, weil gerade
die Apple Cloud,
das ist so Ultra-Vendor-Login alles.
Ich
verwende iOS auch echt
so light wie es geht. Natürlich einen App Store
Account, Apple Account brauchst du.
Aber ich verwende keine Cloud
keine, wie heißt das Ding?
iCloud Storage.
Selbst das Free Storage-Tier verwende
ich nicht.
Über WiFi am besten.
Achso, Backup. Backup über USB.
Ist zwar nicht das schnellste,
aber dann braucht es halt eine halbe Stunde.
Backup mache ich über USB.
Anstöpseln, rüberkopieren.
Über USB mit
iFuse
FS oder so.
Wie heißt das?
Hier, damit.
Damit mounte ich unter Linux
mein iPhone.
Und dann werden die Datenverzeichnisse
rübergeschoben.
Da sagst du im Endeffekt einfach
das musst du alles gar
nicht machen, wenn du es ordentlich
installierst. Das musst du gar nicht machen.
Am Ende sagst du einfach nur hier
ähm
genau.
Ne.
Ich hab's hier über meine Shell-History.
Kannst du dein komplettes iPhone mounten in den Ordner
und dann alles rüberkopieren.
Das ist tatsächlich der größte Vorteil von den
eingebauten Funktionen, dass die einfach funktionieren.
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch das, warum
sich das so gut verkauft. Das funktioniert einfach.
Das ist ja auch das, was 95%
der Anbieter am wichtigsten ist.
Dass sie sich nicht großartig drum kümmern müssen
und es einfach funktioniert.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich ab und zu
iMessage verwende oder FaceTime
mit anderen iPhone-Usern.
Du musst dir keine Gedanken machen, es funktioniert einfach.
Du hast die Telefonnummer der Leute,
rufst an,
machst FaceTime, Call, es geht halt einfach.
Also es hat manchmal
durchaus seinen Charme, wenn es einfach geht.
Ist auch der Grund, warum ich mir fürs
Fahrrad einen Garmin-Computer
gekauft hab und einen Garmin-Rücklicht.
Kannst du pairen miteinander
und dann drückst du halt da auf den Knopf und es geht einfach.
So, also.
Was trendet denn auf ShitHub?
Das finde ich ganz interessant, das habe ich mir mal aufgeschrieben.
Vielleicht testen wir das sogar mal
im Stream. Mal gucken.
Out of
AI.
Irgendwelche Umfragen,
Dinger. Keine Ahnung, juckt mich nicht.
AI.
Äh, AI.
Piehole. Swift.
Open-Source-Cross-Platform-
Alternative to Airdrop.
Okay, das ist cool.
Das Ding ist bloß, wahrscheinlich brauchen
es beide Seiten und
haben es dann nicht.
Aber coole Idee.
Das ist immer ein Zeichen,
für das sie das ernst meinen, wenn sie was im App-Store
haben. Ist aber cool, dass
man Airdroppen könnte zu einer Linux-Kiste.
Sehr praktisch, wenn man einfach
nur mal irgendwie ein Foto oder
ein Video, was man aufgenommen hat, rüberpacken will.
Gut, die Linux-Kiste braucht
dann höchstwahrscheinlich Bluetooth,
aber haben ja die meisten Rechner
heutzutage.
Coolify.
PAP.
Coolify AO.
Ganz ehrlich,
allein schon, weil es PAP ist,
habe ich da wenig Bock drauf, wenn man da was dran stricken will.
Braucht man nicht.
AI.
Local Pilot AI, juckt mich nicht.
U-Block. Okay, nice.
Alternative Frontend to YouTube.
Moment. Ohne
Werbungszwang dann.
AI Plays Pokémon.
Oder wie die Amis sagen, Pokémon.
Noch mehr
YouTube-Stells.
AI.
AI? Vermutlich.
Vermutlich auch AI.
Enterprise
Distributed Relational
Database.
Können wir nicht einfach Postgres
verwenden? High Performance.
Horizontal Scalability.
Da sieht man schon mal, wie outdated die sind,
anstatt es nicht einfach diagonal zu skalieren.
Und sie sind kompatibel
mit SQL-Standards.
Krasse Dudes.
Wir können auch einfach Postgres verwenden. Warum sollte ich das
verwenden jetzt? Ah, weil
Cloud Native und skalierbar.
Ja. Okay.
Das ist natürlich mit Postgres...
Also Postgres tut sich ja ein bisschen
schwer mit Multinode und
super krassem rauf und runter skalieren.
Vieles kann einem durch den Postgres
Operator in Kubernetes abgenommen werden.
Wobei ich persönlich immer noch der Meinung bin,
Datenbank in Kubernetes ist meistens
keine allzu geile Idee.
Aber kann man machen. Man kann auch einfach
den Managed Service verwenden von Google
zum Beispiel. Wobei sie sich glaube ich
auch nicht wirklich großartig um skalieren kümmern.
Ich weiß nicht, was es da für CloudSQL
Möglichkeiten gibt.
Bis jetzt fallen mir eigentlich bloß
stärkere VMs ein.
Man könnte aber auch...
Also wenn man wirklich den Anspruch hat,
eine
Multi-Write-Read
Datenbank zu haben in der Cloud.
Da gibt es ja sowas wie CassandraDB.
Also das Problem beim
skalieren von Datenbanken ist ja
gar nicht so sehr Multiple-Read,
sondern
Multiple-Write.
So der klassische Ansatz, Datenbanken
hochverfügbar und skalierbar
zu machen ist ja, man hat
eine Datenbank,
nennen wir es mal eine Datenbankklasse.
Und davon hast du einen Masternode.
Das ist der einzige, der schreiben darf
in die Datenbank.
Und du hast mehrere Read-Only-Nodes,
die lesen können.
Das ist meistens kein großes Problem
und oftmals auch genau der richtige
Ansatz, weil viel mehr gelesen
wird aus der Datenbank als geschrieben wird
in die Datenbank. Sollte das allerdings
für diesen Anwendungsfall nicht passen,
dann muss man sich was anderes überlegen.
Und da bin ich
nicht so sehr drin im Database-Game,
um mich da groß auszukennen, wie man das
beispielsweise mit Postgres gescheit machen würde.
Ich persönlich würde vermuten, dass es mit
Postgres auch nur bis zu einem gewissen Grad
überhaupt möglich ist, weil es muss ja
seinen Grund haben, warum sich die letzten Jahre über
noch
neben Postgres und den
klassischen Systemen
so Cloud-Native-Datenbank-Sachen
etabliert haben.
Also das Erste, was mir einfallen würde, ist glaube ich
CassandraDB oder was?
CouchbaseDB? Ich glaube es war CassandraDB
für weltweit verteilte
Datenbanken. Moment, was?
Customized Firmware für die
Nintendo Switch? Was ist das hier?
Was gibt's hier? Leute,
eigene Switch-Champ
Firmware-Implementierung in
Comminger. Okay, Nintendo
darf es nicht benutzen?
Nee. Nintendo darf
es benutzen, uneingeschränkt, oder?
Ich hab die erste Switch-Version.
Ich könnte theoretisch meine Switch-Hacker
nennen.
Also, der Axt-Mörderpanda
möchte was wissen, und zwar
er versucht hier gerade parallel
einen neuen Router aufzusetzen
und will vorher die IP-Adresse gleich
zu setzen wie die meisten meines aktuellen
Routers. Haben den hier einfach lokal
am Laptop eingesteckt, aber über
Browser drauf zugreifen funktioniert einfach nicht.
Wie finde ich den denn jetzt?
Wahrscheinlich hat sich dein Router
per DHCP in der IP gezogen von
deinem schon bestehenden
Router, würde ich jetzt mal vermuten.
Die einfachste Variante dürfte
sein, du stöpselst deinen Rechner
direkt an den Router dran. Ach nee, Moment!
Du hast, ja,
das kannst du machen.
Dann musst du ins Handbuch
gucken, was das Ding für eine Default-IP hat.
Weil du kannst
auch
IP-Add oder IF-Config machen
und mal gucken, ob dein
Rechner, der an diesem Router hängt,
schon eine IP bekommen hat.
Wenn nämlich dein Rechner schon eine IP bekommen hat,
dann hat er höchstwahrscheinlich
dann auch den Router als
Gateway drinstehen.
Mach mal IP-Add oder IF-Config
oder
IP-Config
oder so. Ja, wenn er die
bekommen hat, dann hat der Router per DHCP nichts
verteilt. Aber die meisten Router geben sich
standardmäßig irgendeine Default-IP
aus, frag mich nicht
192.168.
55.1
oder so.
Die kommen aber auch damit hoch.
Aber die meisten
Konsumer-Dinger nicht.
WLAN aus, natürlich. Du sollst schon
exklusiv den Router benutzen.
Guck mal IF-Config, ob der was
bekommen hat.
Ob dein Laptop schon eine IP
gekriegt hat vom Router. Ansonsten resettest
du den Router nochmal, lässt ihn neu starten und guckst
ob er dann was kriegt. Und dann bleibt dir eigentlich
nichts anderes übrig, außer Default-IP im Handbuch
nachzugucken. Und sollte dein
Laptop keine DHCP
bekommen vom Router, dann musst du dein Laptop
und die Netzwerkkarte in der IP aus dem Default-Netzwerk
geben und auf die Default-IP
vom Router gehen.
Immer ein bisschen...
Schick mal das Modell, wir gucken jetzt mal.
Wir gucken jetzt mal zusammen ins Handbuch hier
on stream. Was ist das für
ein Router? So.
Was haben wir denn hier zu bieten? Was können wir uns
denn heute angucken?
Ja, Maurice hat ein neues Video, den gucke ich
ja immer gerne. Microsoft kauft
endlich Blizzard und kann es nur besser werden,
oder? Ehrlich gesagt,
man würde jetzt pauschal denken,
es kann ja nur besser werden, aber man darf nicht vergessen,
auch Microsoft und auch
der Xbox-Chef und die ganzen
Manager da, die sind jetzt auch nicht unbedingt
bekannt dafür, so die puren
Menschenfreunde zu sein.
So, also, TP-Link, wir gucken jetzt mal
zusammen, Chatge.
TP-Link AC
Archer. Ah, okay,
ich dachte du hast so einen Stealth-Bomber
Router, aber der sieht ja noch halbwegs normal aus.
So, ähm, Support.
Ja, ich hoffe mal
V5. Wo
haben die das Handbuch, Leute?
Äh, Manual?
Wo ist es denn? Seht ihr irgendwas? Hier, Userguide.
Okay, Userguide.
Dann lasst uns doch mal zusammen reingucken.
Frontpanel,
Backpanel, Setup. Login.
Connect your hardware. Position your router.
Connect your router. Okay, da haben wir es doch.
Position your router. Connect to your router.
So.
If your internet comes from...
Bla bla bla bla, das wollen wir doch noch gar nicht.
Modem.
Was wollen die denn hier?
Hier, das ist das. Okay, das hast
du wahrscheinlich, das hast du wahrscheinlich gemacht.
Kein Internet, also
keine IP. Das hat das eine mit dem anderen
nichts zu tun. Du kriegst
eine lokale IP von deinem
Router an deinem Notebook, ob der Internet hat oder nicht.
Das ist egal.
Turn off WiFi on your computer.
Ja, das ist gut.
WiFi off turn.
Und dann einstecken. Okay, ja, das ist easy.
Und dann?
Und dann solltest du eigentlich schon
solltest du eigentlich bei DHCP
eine IP von dem Router kriegen.
Und dann kannst du auf tplinkwifi.net
Gut, ja, das ist die Frage,
ob da die Auflösung richtig funktioniert,
wenn irgendwas anderes nicht tut.
Also als erstes würde ich
tatsächlich WiFi ausschalten,
Laptop einschalten,
Router neu starten, also Laptop einstöpseln,
Router neu starten
und dann per
ifconfig gucken, ob mein Interface
eine IP bekommen hat.
Und wir können da default
Nee, gibt es das nicht.
Nee.
Also,
wir müssen mal gucken, wie das hier auflöst.
Aber das ist das erste.
WiFi ausschalten am Router,
äh, nicht am Router, alter, WiFi ausschalten
am Notebook, Notebook einstöpseln
am Router, Router neu starten und dann
nach 20-30 Sekunden
gucken.
Ja, anscheinend schon.
Es scheint default zu sein, zumindest laut
Handbuch. Und dann ifconfig gucken,
ob das Interface eine IP gekriegt hat.
Und mal schauen, ob die
Link-LEDs
auch überhaupt leuchten,
zwischen Router und Laptop.
Genau, und wenn es gebraucht ist, einmal
resetten. Ja, ja, also resetten
auf jeden Fall, wenn der nicht
neu ist. Der Router.
Den musst du
in LAN einstecken, dein
Notebook, nicht in WAN.
WiFi ausschalten am Notebook,
LAN-Port 1
in den Laptop und dann
ifconfig am Laptop gucken, ob er eine
IP gekriegt hat oder ipconfig,
wie auch immer, ob du unter Linux oder Windows oder
Mac bist. Wahrscheinlich
unter Windows. Unter Windows ist es
ipconfig. Und es ist nicht einfach nur
ipconfig, sondern chat, wie ist es
unter Windows? ipconfig?
Ich glaube, ipconfig-a
oder, nee,
all, all, genau.
ipconfig-all.
Ich wusste das natürlich und wollte nur
checken, ob dein Chat das auch weiß.
Ja, genau. Und dann kannst du gucken, ob
dein Interface eine IP hat.
Wenn dein Interface eine IP bekommen hat von dem Router,
dann sieht es gut aus. Dann kannst du weitermachen.
So, also.
Shit-up-Trends haben wir, glaube ich, durch.
War nichts
sonderlich Spannendes. Lass uns
grad nochmal just for fun gucken,
ob es in der
.net-Welt irgendwelche spannenden Sachen gibt.
Nope. Ein DNS-Server
in .net. Warum denn das?
Moment, hab ich den nicht auch mal
verwendet? Chat, hab ich nicht mal
irgendwas gebaut,
wo ich selbst einen DNS-Server gebraucht
hab in meinem .net-Account? Und da haben
wir den verwendet. Was war das denn
nochmal?
Ich weiß es! Die Wetterstation.
Das Display von der Wetterstation
hat China-Chinesen
DNS-Auflösung gebraucht. Die hab ich
gefaked mit
dem DNS-Server hier. Ja, genau. Den hab ich
schon mal benutzt sogar.
Switch-Emulator.
Farming-Steamcard.
Unity. OSU.
WeebsIn.
China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Tiling-Window-Manager.
For Windows.
Oh je, Leute.
Bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Inspired bei i3 und Polybar.
Wann gab's das
erste Release davon?
Das kenn ich noch gar nicht. Wie alt
ist denn das?
2021. Okay, das ist auch noch
nicht so alt. Das schreib ich mir
auch mal auf. Das probieren wir irgendwann mal aus.
Aber nicht
in meinem Host-System,
sondern in der 4M.
i3,
das wird was, ey.
Das sieht auf jeden Fall cool aus.
Pogu. Gefällt mir
jetzt eigentlich auf den ersten Blick mal
ganz gut. Keine Task-Leiste.
Ja, umso besser, oder?
Ich glaub, das ist das Letzte, was man braucht.
Interessant. Das
probieren wir mal aus. Da bin ich
gespannt, ob das taugt.
EL-Spy. Ich dachte, das wird nicht mehr weiterentwickelt.
Background-Jobs.
AP.
Ah ja, natürlich nur,
um Linux-Distributionen runterzuladen.
Oh, Maui. Da warte ich immer noch
auf die Meldung von Microsoft, dass Ball eingestellt wird.
Was ist damit?
Da war ich beeindruckt. Geht was?
Peppi. Osu.
WeepsIn.
Sollte es dir mal angucken. Ja, aber nicht on-Stream.
Warum soll ich mir Pipe-Video on-Stream angucken?
Couchbase.
Datenbanken ist halt nicht so das, wo ich richtig Plan von hab.
Der hat seit 6 Jahren
mindestens
einen Commit jeden Tag. Krasser Dude.
Und eindeutig
fast so gut wie der Fiat Champ.
Was macht eigentlich,
wo wir gerade dabei sind?
Last Week.
Oh, man.
Ich hab keinen Kopf, gerade
groß weiterzumachen.
Ja, nicer Dude. Wie geht's dir?
Was das ist?
Genau.
Smart Home-Integration für Fiat.
Fiat und
Dodge
Trucks
und Alfa Romeo
und Jeep, glaube ich. Aber hauptsächlich,
aber hauptsächlich
für Fiat.
Weil ich hab das für meinen eigenen Fiat gebaut.
Das Ding ist halt,
ja, wie gesagt, ich wurde gestern
auf dem Fahrradweg umgefahren.
Und was macht dein Laptop?
So, dann lasst uns mal schauen.
Was können wir uns denn jetzt angucken?
Was ist das denn?
Das ist ein
Fiat 500e.
Und da kannst du
ein paar Werte von abrufen.
Leider kann man das halt nicht direkt vom Auto.
Ich bin Fahrrad gefahren und wurde
von einem Auto umgefahren auf dem Fahrradweg.
Und
das bekommt man nicht direkt vom Auto,
sondern über die, naja,
sagen wir mal, inoffizielle API
von Fiat.
Was ist das?
Password Storage Tierlist.
Encryption Hashing.
Salting.
Moment, das eine und das andere,
also,
das ist nicht entweder oder.
Also, du kannst
was haschen, okay,
dann kannst du es nicht encrypten. Das lasse ich mir noch gefallen, ja.
Aber das ergänzt
das nur, also,
ich würde nicht unbedingt sagen, dass das eine Tierlist
ist, sondern
unterschiedlichste Sachen.
Naja, wer weiß, wer weiß, was
YouTube da denkt
jetzt, oder der Ersteller,
müssen wir mal gucken.
Top Recruiter Gehalt.
Er ist Key Account Manager
für Zeitarbeit Fachkräfte.
Lohnt sich das? Ah, das gucken wir mal.
Personalverschacherungs-Dudes.
Na, eigentlich
sollte man
nicht
unbedingt Passwörter,
nee,
encryptet man nicht Passwörter, sondern
Passwörter, und das
mit einem Sort dabei. Und haschen
hat mit Encryption nichts zu tun.
Jetzt bräuchten wir
Algorithmen verstehen, der könnte uns das alles
ganz super fachmännisch korrekt
erklären. Ich kann's euch nur
90% korrekt erklären.
Haschen ist ja keine
Encryption.
Weil haschen ist one way, und
Encryption ist, ja,
fair und entschlüsselbar, also,
in beide Richtungen. Ja gut,
du kannst den Hash
Encrypted übertragen, ja.
Du kannst auch das Passwort Encrypten
und übertragen, aber das eine hat mit dem anderen
nichts zu tun.
Du steckst den Sort und das Passwort
in deine Hash-Funktion rein,
und du brauchst den Sort
im Klartext,
und ja, den Hash-Algorithmus,
dass du es auf der
anderen Seite auch überprüfen kannst.
Weiterer Grund dafür, warum man
keine Encryption und
irgendwelche Security-Sachen selbst programmieren sollte,
sondern irgendwas Fertiges nimmt.
Nicht, dass sie nicht auch
Probleme haben können. OpenSSL hatte jetzt
die letzten Jahre über ja auch die ein oder anderen Sicherheitslücken.
Aber die
Chancen sind deutlich geringer, als wenn man selbst
was macht.
Ich guck das Video jetzt aber gar nicht.
Wir gucken uns jetzt an.
Top-Rekruter-Gehalt.
Er ist Key-Account-Manager für Zeit.
Was genau macht eigentlich,
das hab ich jetzt schon öfters gehört, und eigentlich
würde man sagen, ja,
man könnte es ja mittlerweile wissen.
Ich weiß bis heute nicht, was ein Key-Account-Manager
eigentlich genau ist.
Was ist...
Okay, was ist ein
Key... Okay, ein Key-Account-Manager
kam, sind für die Betreuung
der wichtigsten Kunden zuständig.
In der Regel sind es die sogenannten
Schlüsselkunden, die für den
meisten Umsatz... Ah ja, ah ja, okay, also
sprich, sagen wir mal,
wir als
relativ große Versicherung in Deutschland
sind irgendwie Premium-Kunde
bei Google, zum Beispiel, ja?
Dann wäre der Typ,
der sich bei Google um uns kümmert,
der Key-Account-Manager für uns.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Warum ist es denn eine Führungskraft?
Das eine hat doch mit dem anderen gar nichts zu tun.
Naja gut, wir gucken uns das jetzt mal an.
Ich hoffe,
ja, das ist doch gut, je nach Position,
muss dann ja auch immer ordentlich Kohle rumkommen.
Also...
Dann schieß mal los mit eurem neuen Projekt.
Also die ersten Worte, die immer folgen, sind natürlich
Sklavenhandel.
Jaja, na gut.
Wenn man sich manche Personalversicherungs-Dinger
anguckt,
vielleicht rein rechtlich gesehen
nicht, aber
es hat, würde ich mal sagen, schon die einen
oder anderen parallel.
Der mit der Frau vereinbart, Kamil.
Das ist ja wirklich sehr, sehr wenig Geld.
Das kann man fast nicht machen.
Ich finde auch, dass das Gehalt, das ich
im Monat bekomme,
im Vergleich zu jemandem, der eine
wichtigere Arbeit macht, teilweise auch zu hoch ist.
Okay.
Wenn man wichtige Arbeit
definieren würde,
zu, ja,
wenn man sich das im Verhältnis angucken würde,
dann würde ich sagen,
ich würde sagen,
wenn man sich das im Verhältnis angucken würde,
was Leute beispielsweise im Altersheim
und so leisten,
für die Allgemeinheit,
dann würde ich sagen, ja, dann verdiene ich auch zu viel.
Das würde ich auch unterschreiben.
Aber ich muss sagen,
ich finde den Vergleich immer ein bisschen
problematisch.
Das heißt ja nicht,
dass
der eine weniger verdienen muss,
damit der andere mehr verdienen muss.
Man könnte einfach alle Leute ordentlich bezahlen.
Aber bei manchen Jobs
hängt halt einfach, und jetzt mal
Business speak,
hängt halt wahrscheinlich einfach nicht genug Geld
dran, als dass man eben,
ja, das Geld in die Hand nimmt
für solche Stellen.
Ich denke, wir können alle relativ unstrittig sagen,
dass es für,
ja, für die Allgemeinheit enorm wichtig ist,
dass wir Leute haben, die in der Pflege arbeiten,
im Krankenhaus arbeiten und sonst was.
Und,
wenn man jetzt sagen würde, was ist wichtiger?
Jemand, der sich um die Opas im Altersheim kümmert,
oder jemand, der dafür sorgt,
dass bei einer Versicherung, bei einem Ausfall
die Server schnell wieder laufen,
könntest du sagen, ja klar, der Typ, der im Altersheim
arbeitet, aber
Cack Business ist das nicht so.
Weil wenn du mal überlegst,
wo da mehr Geld dran hängt, also
aus sozialer, menschlicher Sicht,
kann man das, denke ich,
relativ einstimmig sagen,
aber aus Cack Business Sicht
ist das nicht so, weil der Opa im
Altersheim kostet Geld
und bringt kein Geld
und wenn du
guckst, was so ein Systemausfall
verursacht in
Millionenhöhe,
dann ist es halt klar, dass man
sich lieber jemand hinsetzt,
der sich darum kümmert, als den Leuten im Altersheim
gescheit Geld zu bezahlen, was Cacke ist,
aber aus Business Sicht
irgendwie
die, sagen wir mal,
die Entwicklung vielleicht nicht rechtfertigt, aber
halbwegs erklärt.
Und
ich denke mir halt immer,
also ich habe mir so Fragen auch schon öfters gestellt,
so nach dem Motto, Alter, guck mal,
du verdienst so viel Kohle im Vergleich
zu jemand, der wirklich wichtige Sachen
für die Allgemeinheit macht, aber
die Hintergedanken sind halt,
irgendjemand hat es ja mal
sich überlegt und gesagt, ja, wir
geben das Geld dafür aus, okay.
Und man überlegt sich zum Beispiel,
wenn man jetzt einen Job in der IT hat
und vielleicht bei einer größeren Bank oder bei einer
Versicherung oder bei irgendwas, wo
wirklich viel Geld dran hängt,
dann hat sich irgendjemand
dort mal überlegt, okay,
ein Systemausfall kostet
uns 20 Millionen am Tag.
Ich sage jetzt einfach, keine
realen Bezüge, Leute,
denkt mir jetzt einfach was aus, ja.
Irgendjemand hat sich dort mal überlegt, okay,
ein Systemausfall kostet uns 20 Millionen
am Tag, das heißt,
wenn wir da jetzt 3
Leute hinsetzen, selbst wenn die
nicht so viel machen,
wenn die einfach nur dafür sorgen, dass
im Fall der Fälle, ja,
und sagen wir mal, wir haben einen Ausfall
so alle 2 Jahre mal
und wenn die nur da sitzen
und im Fall der Fälle
dafür sorgen, dass das System nicht einen Tag weg
ist, sondern nur 2 Stunden,
dann hat sich das schon gelohnt.
Das wird irgendjemand da gerechnet
haben und feststellen, okay, das ist sinnvoll
und wir brauchen gescheite Leute
und buttert da richtig Geld rein.
Das ist das, was bei einer Bank oder bei einer
Versicherung garantiert passiert, was im
Altersheim so halt nicht
ist.
Daher kommt halt, denke ich, auch irgendwie dieses
Diskrepanz zwischen dem, was man eben als
für die Allgemeinheit, ja,
wichtig ansieht und
trotzdem der irgendwie relativ
geringen Bezahlung. Wobei man sagen muss,
das ist gar nicht
mehr so, habe ich letztens einen Artikel drüber
gelesen, es ist anscheinend hauptsächlich
dort, wo die Leute fest
angestellt sind in der Pflege und im
Altersheim, dass dort die Löhne
wirklich mega beschissen sind
und was ich jetzt auch schon öfters gelesen
habe, wenn man dort flexibel ist
und bei einer Zeitarbeitsfirma arbeitet,
dass man richtig
ordentlich gut Kohle machen kann.
Das heißt natürlich dann auch, man
springt irgendwo ein für 2
Wochen in einem
Altersheim in Stuttgart
und dann irgendwie 2 Wochen
später in einem Altersheim in Mannheim oder so, ich weiß nicht
wie krass das läuft oder ob das auch mal ein halbes
Jahr, Jahr läuft, ist sicherlich auch nicht
jeder Manns und jeder Frau Sache,
aber da, zumindest was man so liest,
kann man wohl auch richtig
Kohle verdienen, wenn man das
macht,
ja, so flexibel.
Da kann man wohl richtig Geld verdienen.
Also man kann, glaube ich,
pauschal gar nicht sagen, dass es schlecht bezahlt ist,
wenn man fest angestellt ist, dann ist es
wohl echt beschissen. Das ist genauso wie
beispielsweise letztens
Frau vorm Kulisse
arbeitet im Kindergarten und so, das ist auch,
wenn es mal vergleicht,
der Witz, was die Leute da verdienen.
Na gut, gucken wir uns das jetzt mal an.
Hi, mein Name ist Eike, ich bin
29 Jahre alt und gemeinsam
mit meinem Team dekortieren wir
Fachkräfte aus Osteuropa für den deutschen Arbeitsmarkt.
Morgen!
Geht's gut?
Auf das Büro hätte ich ja
gar keinen Bock, da irgendwie mit,
keine Ahnung, 12 Leuten im Büro
zu hocken und du kriegst
den ganzen Tag wieder deine Kollegen telefonieren
und sowas.
Da könnte ich mich nicht konzentrieren, weil...
Wir haben eine Recruiting-Abteilung soweit,
die beiden sind für Kroatien
zuständig und teilweise auch Bulgarien.
Unsere beiden Mädels hier machen die rumänische Flanke
soweit und die beiden sind hier für Ungarn zuständig.
Wir rekrutieren eben Fachkräfte aus
Osteuropa, allerdings
eben zur Personalüberlassung.
Bedeutet, wir suchen beispielsweise
Schweißer aus Rumänien oder aus Polen
oder aus Tschechien oder der Slowakei oder ähnliches,
die dann bei unseren Endkunden
eingesetzt werden.
Die Endkunden bezahlen wahrscheinlich richtig
Kohle. Ich weiß ja nicht, was
denen ihr Satz ist oder was sie davon abschreiben.
So irgendwie mal mindestens
drei Monatsgehälter oder sowas. Ich weiß ja nicht,
was da üblich ist. Das wird
ordentlich oder permanent wahrscheinlich
pro Monat, das wird permanent
Asche kriegen. Im Prinzip wird
wahrscheinlich hinten beim
eigentlichen Arbeiter auch noch ganz gut
was ankommen im Vergleich zu Rumänien.
Ja,
aber im Vergleich zu direkt
wahrscheinlich nicht. Am Ende
könnte ich mir vorstellen, lohnt sich das aber für alle.
Am Ende
könnte ich mir echt vorstellen, lohnt sich das für alle.
Vielleicht sehe ich das auch zu blauäugig, aber vielleicht
also ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen,
sonst würden es die Leute ja nicht machen.
Und ausgelegt ist es so, dass nach zwölf
Monaten eine Übernahme in
Stammpersonal erfolgt, weil das so Handwerksberufe
sind, die in Deutschland
mittlerweile zu selten ausgeübt werden
oder auch erlernt werden. Ich koordiniere
im Endeffekt das Ganze hier. Meine Abteilung
ist die rechte hier hinten.
Um neun Uhr
würden wir uns kurz via Zoom mit unserem
Niederlassungsleiter. Aha, Zoom.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich weniger mag.
Teams oder Zoom? Ja, es ist Zoom. Ich mag Zoom
weniger. Teams geht mir
auch auf den Sack, aber Zoom
jedes Mal, wenn ich mich damit,
wenn ich nur in den Call rein muss, habe ich schon Anfälle.
In Polen zusammensetzen,
da müssen wir einen neuen Auftrag finalisieren
für den Bereich Zahntechnik. Das ist für uns auch
komplett neu, deswegen mal schauen, was da rauskommt.
Wir sind viel im Bereich Troubleshooting dann auch unterwegs,
wenn irgendwas bewerber- oder mitarbeiterseitig
nicht klappt oder kundenseitig auch nicht klappt.
Ja, wir gehen jetzt kurz rüber in den
Besprechungsraum.
Wenn er sagt, Fachkräfte aus
Osteuropa, das erinnert
mich, wo ich beim Elektriker angerufen habe,
hier bei mir im Ort, als ich mir
ich wollte mir so ein Ladegerät
fürs Elektroauto in Hof bauen lassen.
Und
da habe ich angerufen beim Elektriker,
hier um die Ecke.
Da habe ich einfach geguckt, Google Maps
und
das Erste, bei dem Ersten, wo ich angerufen
habe, ging einer dran mit einem super
krassen, weiß ich nicht,
russischen, ukrainischen, polnischen
Akzent. Ich kann das
gar nicht richtig einordnen.
Und das Erste,
ich habe dem erklärt, ohne Scheiß,
das Erste, was der geantwortet hat, war,
als ich ihm erklärt habe, was ich haben will,
also erstmal hat er gemeint, oh, Chef nicht da, oder sowas.
Und da habe ich ihm gesagt, ja, und das und das.
Und das Erste, was ich von ihm gehört habe, ist,
das wird teuer.
Da habe ich mir schon gedacht, okay, ihr habt
weder was angeguckt noch wisst ihr genau,
was Sache ist, das wird denn teuer.
Da habe ich gesagt, okay, ja, ähm, okay,
vielleicht rufe ich doch lieber woanders an.
Latenox,
danke für den Sub.
Okay, dann habe ich bei einem anderen angerufen,
hier um die Ecke, und das war
deutlich seriöser. Der hat gesagt, ah, ich könnte
nächste Woche mal kurz vorbeikommen,
gucken. Hat er geguckt, hat gesagt,
hier, easy, können wir nächste Woche Freitag
machen. Das ging tatsächlich erstaunlicherweise
sehr schnell.
Hat dann einen von seinen Jungs vorbeigeschickt,
und der hat da zwei Stunden
gebaut, und dann hatte ich eine Ladestation
im Hof.
Die Stühle sehen äußerst unergonomisch
aus, ja.
Kamil, grüß dich.
Beste Antwort.
Hallo, wir sind vom...
Eigentlich habe ich gar keinen Bock auf euch,
kann es aber nicht sagen. Ja, passt
soweit.
So, dann schieß mal los mit eurem
neuen Projekt. Wie viel Kilo?
11, weil 11 musst du nicht
die Kurs genehmigen lassen.
Sie heißt Martina.
Ich kann dir einen Vortrag in den Ladestall
aufzusenden. Okay, habt ihr über den Preis
schon gesprochen, oder was die Dame verdienen soll?
Ja, vor allem haben wir
kurz gesprochen, 2,6.
2,5, 2,6.
Vor allem müssen...
Okay, das ist
ja echt nicht viel. Okay, je nachdem, für was?
Ja. Also, für die ist es
wahrscheinlich viel. Kennst du EVCC?
Das sagt mir was.
Ich kann es jetzt gerade nicht so wirklich
zuhören. Das sagt mir aber auf jeden Fall was
in dem Kontext, ja.
Unbedingt eine Unterkünfte
in der Gegend.
Wir werden einfach ohne Auto
anreisen, aber muss ich nochmal nachfragen.
Gut.
Super. Danke dir.
Mach es gut. Ciao.
Spannende Geschichte mit der Nummer.
Wenn sie ohne Auto kommt, wird es echt herausfordernd, glaube ich.
Eine Unterkunft in Stuttgart,
ist ja so schon sportlich, aber dann noch ohne Auto.
Also im Endeffekt ist es so, dass
wir bei einer Personalüberlassung
den künftigen
Mitarbeitern...
Wie viel verdienst du im Monat? Zu viel.
Also, nicht wirklich zu viel, aber
gleich 10, was ich eben gesagt habe.
Wahrscheinlich zu viel.
Bei uns als Standard immer Einzelzimmer.
Da ist das Lohnbestandteil drin.
Das bedeutet, wir bezahlen die Unterkunft
und ziehen es dann den Mitarbeitern vom Lohn im Endeffekt ab.
Ich schaue mal nach die Unterkunft
erstmal.
Ja, und dann können wir ja weitergehen.
Also,
ohne den Zweier zu nahe zu wollen,
das Erste, was mir einfällt,
wenn ich ihn hier mit dem Goldkettchen sehe,
ist, es wirkt so ein bisschen
wie Russisch in Kassel, oder?
Wenn er vor der Tür steht.
Du musst jetzt bezahlen.
Hat irgendwie was davon.
Ja, weitergehen.
Okay, gut, bis gleich.
Tschüss.
Gut.
Also, der würde ich auch bezahlen, wenn er vor der Tür steht.
Wenn wir uns mal kurz
den Vertrieb anschauen bei uns,
da gibt es gerade ein paar Problemchen,
aber die kriegen wir auch gelöst.
Wir sind heute abgemeldet wegen Auftragseinbruch.
Unser Ziel ist es, dass wir
die Kandidaten, die jetzt ohne Auftrag dastehen,
schnellstmöglich wieder in Lohn und Brot bringen.
Wir haben jetzt vier Lackiervorbereiter,
oder Lackierhelfer, oder?
Naja, Chat würde ich nicht sagen.
Hört sich vielleicht etwas...
Ich finde, die Aufmachung sieht alles vielleicht ein bisschen unseriös aus,
aber ich glaube, dass das ein legit,
wie soll ich sagen,
ein vollkommen normales in der heutigen Zeit
Anwendungs...
Geschäftstätigkeitsfeld ist.
Die suchen halt händeringend Leute
und irgendwo müssen die Leute herkommen.
Und nachdem jetzt der Handwerksbetrieb
hier um die Ecke
nicht nach Rumänien fährt
und dann sagt, Jungs, wollt ihr mal bei uns anfangen?
Ich finde das ein vollkommen normales Tätigkeitsfeld.
Dass da sicherlich viel
vielleicht fragwürdige Sachen teilweise laufen,
nicht so zum Vorteil von denen,
die am Ende da anfangen,
mag alles sein,
aber so das Feld an sich ist doch
in der heutigen Zeit vollkommen normal.
Würde ich gar nicht sagen.
Ein bisschen sicherlich.
Ich weiß zum Beispiel damals,
als ich beim Provider gearbeitet habe,
dort wurden auch Leute quasi
vermietet an
Unternehmen in Frankfurt
zum Beispiel,
die sich dort dann um IT-Sachen gekümmert haben
und wenn man dort geguckt hat,
was die dort für einen bezahlt haben
versus das, was man kriegt, war natürlich ein riesengroßer Unterschied.
Aber es gibt ja
nach wie vor Unternehmen,
die suchen Leute und es gibt Leute, die wollen das machen.
Und die vermitteln das.
Das würde ich jetzt nicht pauschal sagen,
dass das irgendwas ja
un... wie könnte man das nennen?
Pauschal was unseriöses ist.
Die machen halt was,
was gemacht werden muss.
Und dass sie dabei was verdienen wollen, ist ja auch okay.
Wenn man irgendwann im Lebensmittelbereich
oder in der Pharmaindustrie schon mal gearbeitet hat,
wäre es super.
Also wir schauen halt eben, wir haben Kunden,
die haben gewisse Voraussetzungen beispielsweise.
Es wird B1 Deutsch vorausgesetzt,
es wird eine Erfahrung
im Lebensmittelfarma-Chemie-Bereich
vorausgesetzt. Das kommt immer ganz auf die
Kundenanforderungen drauf an, wo wir die Leute platzieren können.
Ja.
Nee, die Bewerber gar nicht.
Der Ablauf ist so, dass unser Kunde
uns in einem gewissen Stundensatz für jede Produktivstunde
dann uns bezahlt.
Boah, krass!
Pro Stunde!
Alter, das...
Das wird teuer, ey.
Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, die kriegen pauschal
irgendwie ein, zwei, drei
Monatsgehälter oder so oder irgendwie
eine Prämie oder so,
dass da nochmal pro Stunde drauf
gehauen wird. Alter, das geht ja mal
richtig ins Geld, ey.
Und davon kann man dann auch ausgehen, dass
wahrscheinlich ein nicht unerheblicher
Teil beim Vermittler landet.
Also, dass
wahrscheinlich der, der die Leute bekommt,
echt ordentlich bezahlen
muss dafür. Und derjenige,
der was bekommt, der wird
wahrscheinlich auch gut Geld bekommen
für rumänische Verhältnisse, aber
ein Großteil dessen an Differenz
landet beim Vermittler. Ist ja auch
okay, ne? Die müssen ja auch Geld verdienen.
Aber das wird echt
teuer, könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Dann lass ich dich mal in Ruhe.
Also, da machen wir schon drei, vier Pausen,
würde ich sagen, am Tag, wo man kurz ein Espresso
dann zu uns nimmt.
Ich find das
immer wieder komisch, weil
ich hab das Gefühl, gerade in IT,
alle saufen Kaffee
und trinken auch Cola und Energydrinks
und sowas. Sehe ich bei uns auf der Arbeit
auch. Ich bin der Einzige, gefühlt,
der weder Kaffee noch Energydrinks
noch Cola zu sich nimmt.
Gar nix. Ich trinke eigentlich nur Wasser.
Was haben wir denn für ein Problem?
Frau *** will mit dem Auto anreisen,
aber mit Partner und kleinen Haustieren.
Problem Nummer 2, er zahlt
nach Übernahme 2,8 Viertel
und möchte nicht, dass die Frau
wertet. Was?
Und möchte nicht, dass?
Dass wir die Zahntechnikerin
nicht höher
stellen dürfen wie seine festangestellten
Mitarbeiter, sie aber gleichzeitig
mit Mann und... Ne, das ist natürlich
dann blöd für die Vermittler, weil
da bleibt weniger für die Vermittler
übrig. Auf der anderen Seite
verstehe ich es in gewisser Weise,
weil für die schon bestehenden Mitarbeiter
sieht das natürlich doof aus.
Ja, wenn
eine neue kommt und die verdient viel, viel
mehr als vielleicht die
schon Erfahrenerin
und dann sagen die natürlich
ey, das wollen wir auch haben.
Dass natürlich ein Drittel des Gehalts oder ein Viertel
des Gehalts oder wie viel auch immer beim Vermittler
liegen bleibt. Ja,
das ist denen natürlich dann nicht klar.
Die denken ja so nach dem Motto
oh, die wird viel krasser bezahlt. Wahrscheinlich
kommt am Ende sogar weniger bei der
eigentlichen Fachkraft an als bei denen, die
hier schon eine Weile arbeiten, aber
die Forderung kann ich irgendwie noch nachvollziehen.
Und Katze und Hund nach
Deutschland kommen möchte, deswegen waren
wir uns da vorhin unschlüssig, ob wir das wirklich machen
sollten. Finde ich ne gute Sache, aber kannst
ja vielleicht deine Katze in Ruhe lassen. Also wenn ich irgendwo anders
hinziehen würde, was ich nicht vorhabe,
ja, ich würde auch meine Katze mitnehmen, kann ich meine Katze nicht einfach
da lassen. Will ich auch gar nicht,
dann würde ich lieber den neuen Job nicht anfangen, bevor
ich meine Katze irgendwo zurücklasse.
Weil nachdem wir es durchkalkuliert
haben, der Frau ziemlich wenig Geld
zum Leben bleibt.
Okay, dann müssten wir gleich mal Kamil nochmal anrufen.
Kamil,
weil das ist ja wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr wenig Geld
dann. Das können wir fast nicht machen.
Wir können ja ganz offen sprechen,
unsere Fachkräfte, die wir einstellen,
verdienen durch doppelte Haushaltsführung,
heißt steuerfreie Auslösen,
mehr wie die Festangestellten bei der Firma.
In dem Falle ist es jetzt so, dass statt
2.700 netto,
2.700 brutto anstehen.
Dann rufst du jetzt den Herrn nochmal an, oder?
Welche Strategie?
Ich rufe ihn jetzt an, sage aber auch gleich klipp und klar,
dass sie mit ihrem Mann kommen will und
Haustieren. Und das nur,
wenn sie arbeitet, weil der Mann, denke ich mal,
wird dann keine Arbeit haben.
Der chillt dann hier, oder wie?
Den müssen wir mit dem Kunden besprechen, also
für die ersten Monate vielleicht sogar die ganze Miete übernimmt.
Das wäre vielleicht nochmal ein Anhaltspunkt.
Und was macht der dann?
Der chillt dann den ganzen Tag. Na gut,
der kümmert sich um die Haustiere.
24-7-Betreuung.
Ciao!
Und?
Also ich habe jetzt hier schon 300 Euro Subvention
eingerechnet. Ich sage mal,
die Unterkunft wird
900 Euro kosten,
minus die 300, was wir schon extra bezahlen,
sind dann noch
600 was übrig bleiben. Dann bleiben mir noch
immer 1250-1300
Euro zum Leben.
Sehr gut gemacht, ja, auf jeden Fall.
Auf jeden Fall.
Welche Klischees gibt es in deiner Branche?
Also die ersten Worte, die immer folgen,
sind natürlich Sklavenhandel, was auch noch
so ein Klischee ist. Naja,
naja,
ich sage mal so,
Sklavenhandel ist natürlich zu hart.
Aber
auch wenn ich es jetzt
ein paar Mal verteidigt habe im Video,
aber ein gewisser
Hauch
des
Unseriösen
schwingt bei diesem ganzen Ding schon
ein bisschen mit.
Ganz verhalten gesagt.
Das ist natürlich weit von Sklavenhandel
entfernt. Es ist auch weder illegal noch sonst was.
Ich sehe es auch voll ein, dass die Geld verdienen müssen.
So ein bisschen
so verschachernd ist das halt schon
irgendwo. Aber auf der anderen Seite,
und das darf man auch nicht vergessen,
es gibt Unternehmen, die suchen Leute und es gibt
Leute, die suchen
Jobs. Also ist das ein
vollkommen legitimes Geschäftsfeld.
Das ist halt das klassische Thema Ausbeutung,
aber das haben wir jetzt mit dem Beispiel gerade auch widerlegt.
Es gibt immer noch viele schwarze Schafe
in unserer Branche, das wissen wir.
Auch teilweise
Konkurrenz, die
die Leute nicht so gut behandelt hätten sollen.
Übrigens, hat nichts mit dem Video zu tun.
Gleich gesagt.
Nur mal zum
Thema Sklavenhandel. Wisst ihr eigentlich,
dass wenn jemand
Besuch
erhalten möchte aus
Kolumbien,
jetzt habe ich es, Kolumbien,
ich muss euch das
anders erzählen.
Ein Kollege von mir hat eine Tochter
in Kolumbien. Der war früher in der
USA, in der Army.
Und ja gut, der ist halt ein bisschen rumgekommen
und hat eine Tochter in Kolumbien.
Und die Tochter aus Kolumbien
wollte ihn besuchen
vor
letztes oder vorletztes Jahr zu Weihnachten.
Und die Tochter
ist glaube ich erst 16,
15, 15, 16 so.
Und das war ein riesen
Akt. Das war wirklich
unglaublicher Akt. Und am Tag
wo die eigentlich in Flieger
steigen sollte, um nach Deutschland
zu fliegen, haben sie ihr dort gesagt,
sie darf nicht.
Und warum?
Es war doch alles geklärt.
Dann musste der Kollege nach
Frankfurt fahren, das habe ich mitgekriegt,
sonst wüsste ich das gar nicht.
Der musste nach Frankfurt fahren, in die
kolumbianische Botschaft
dort Fingerabdrücke
abgeben, Ausweis kontrollieren
und Zeug ausfüllen, weil
und jetzt kommt es, weil
Sklavenhandel,
Menschenhandel.
Wahrscheinlich ist das in der Vergangenheit öfters
vorgekommen, dass, also das ist jetzt
meine Interpretation des Ganzen,
wahrscheinlich ist es in der Vergangenheit
öfters vorgekommen,
dass mittelalte
Männer aus Europa,
Deutschland, sich
minderjährige Mädels aus
der Karibik bestellt haben
und
die dann hier so
man weiß ja nicht was da gelaufen ist
und das
soll dadurch verhindert werden.
Weil ganz im Ernst, wenn man
sich das mal so überlegt,
meine 15-jährige Tochter aus Kolumbien,
von der nie jemand vorher was groß gehört hat,
will mich besuchen kommen,
klingt halt schon ein bisschen verdächtig.
Natürlich, niemand was gehört, stimmt ja nicht,
das ist ja offiziell anerkannt und alles
und da musste er wirklich Fingerabdrücke
abgeben,
Ausweis,
dann musste die noch irgendwas
ausfüllen und alles,
was funktioniert hat, das war ein Riesenakt
und die kam dann irgendwie auch erst 2 Tage später
abends an und er musste dann
irgendwie noch 600 Kilometer mit dem Auto rumfahren.
Ich glaube an dem Tag,
ja, mehr oder weniger,
rechtzeitig, aber es war wirklich
mega knapp und
da sieht man mal, da hängt schon
einiges
hinten dran.
Ich finde es auch nicht schlecht,
es hat ja wohl Hand und Fuß, warum das gemacht wird.
Es hat ja wohl Hand und Fuß,
da sieht man mal, was es für Sachen gibt,
woran man so pauschal gar nicht denkt.
Ist schon heftig, ne?
Gut, irgendwie in
2 Jahren oder so ist sie dann 18
und darf so fliegen, wie sie will.
Ja und das Hauptproblem, warum das so ist,
ist wahrscheinlich auch, weil
ihr, also wenn ich das richtig
mitbekommen habe, weil sie nur einen
gültigen kolumbianischen
Pass hatte und
ihren amerikanischen Ausweis
ist halt abgelaufen gewesen.
Also du hast ja automatisch,
wenn dein Vater amerikanische
Staatsbürgerschaft hat, sind die Kinder ja auch
automatisch.
Irgendwie so läuft das.
Ich glaube es gibt 2 Varianten, aber da
habe ich echt wenig Plan von. Ich glaube es gibt
bei den Amis 2 Varianten.
Du kannst, entweder müssen
die Eltern selbst,
das ist seine Tochter,
da gibt es ja auch offizielle Dokumente
dazu und sonst was, also der muss
keinen Bluttest machen oder sowas.
Es muss halt alles aufgenommen werden,
um halt die
formalen Sachen einzuhalten.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Jetzt hast du mich abgelenkt.
Ja genau, es gibt ja glaube ich 2 Sachen, wie man
amerikanischer Staatsbürger werden kann.
Und zwar das Erste ist, die Eltern
sind
Kokona und das Zweite ist,
du kommst auf
amerikanischem Festland irgendwie
zur Welt. Das geht glaube ich auch.
Und
ich glaube,
das sind die 2
Möglichkeiten, wie man
amerikanischer Staatsbürger
werden kann. Das habe ich mal in irgendeinem Beitrag gelesen.
Und es muss wohl, und das ist jetzt
wirklich super krass,
keine Ahnung, aber das habe ich auch irgendwo mal
gelesen, es muss wohl vor einer Weile
ein Trend gegeben haben, für
Chinesen,
dass die Schwanger, wie gesagt,
keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt,
habe ich auch mal irgendwo gelesen,
dass es einen Trend gab, bei Chinesen,
etwas wohlhabenderen Chinesen,
dass die Hochschwanger
in Urlaub geflogen sind,
in die USA,
in der Hoffnung, das Kind kommt in dem Urlaub
in den USA zur Welt,
dass das quasi in den USA geboren ist
und dann den amerikanischen Pass
bekommt
und man so irgendwie die Möglichkeit hat, da hin zu kommen.
Wenn du High IQ, ja die haben ja
ihr Green Card
Programm. So und bei der war
das Problem, dass
ihr amerikanischer Pass abgelaufen war,
sie einen kolumbianischen Pass hatten, deswegen gab es
Riesen hin und her.
Wie ich darauf gekommen bin, ist das, weil er gesagt hat
im Video, Sklaven- und Menschenhandel,
also da gibt es durchaus
mehr als man denkt, weil sonst gäbe es eben diese
Gesetze nicht.
Aber hat nichts mit Personalvermittlung
zu tun, das ist mir nur bei der Gelegenheit eingefallen.
Ich glaube, Leute,
die sowas machen, haben auch nicht wirklich großartiges
Interesse dran, weiter die chinesische
Volksbürgerschaft zu behalten.
Die wollen wahrscheinlich weg.
Die wird es aber immer geben.
Ich würde mir einfach in dem Bereich wünschen,
dass mehr Akzeptanz
an den Tag gelegt wird.
Dass es einfach unumgänglich ist, dass wir
allein schon wegen dem demografischen Wandel
keine Chance haben in Zukunft,
ohne die Fachkräfte aus Osteuropa zu überleben
in Deutschland.
Zu überleben ist jetzt vielleicht
ein bisschen krass ausgedrückt.
Es gibt ja auch noch die Möglichkeit, die Leute kriegen
ein bisschen mehr Kinder und man macht das attraktiver,
dass die Leute hier Kinder kriegen.
Gut, danke euch.
Merci. Es gibt auch Wochen, wo es
dann wirklich sehr anstrengend ist, wo man dann auch merkt,
man läuft ein bisschen auf dem Zahnfleisch.
Wenn ich merke, ich brauche eine kurze Pause
oder ich brauche ein bisschen Auszeit,
dann arbeite ich auch weniger pro Woche.
Also das ist auch kein Thema.
Essen unterwegs?
Es sieht so aus, als haben die sich Pizza bestellt
und zwei Bänke
vor dem Büro stehen und gehen jetzt halt mal kurz
in den Hof.
Quereinstieg. Ich kenne unseren Chef, den Philipp,
schon relativ lange. Dann haben wir uns
in der damaligen Bar von meinem Vater getroffen,
ein bisschen was getrunken und dann sind wir halt
auf den Konsens gekommen, dass wir
künftig beruflich zusammenarbeiten wollen.
Wir sind ein sehr junges Team.
Wir verstehen uns alle auch super.
Die Schnittstellen untereinander können wir sehr gut klären,
was wir für Nachhierarchien haben.
Bei uns ist der Ablauf so,
dass unsere Recruiter
die Kandidaten anrufen,
ob die Vorerfahrung passt,
ob die Dame oder der Herr Fragen hat
zur Arbeit, zur Tätigkeit,
zur Firma oder sonstiges.
Das prüfen wir dann immer noch.
Das ist so ein Qualitätscall im Endeffekt.
Das machst du auch so ab und zu?
In Vertretung von ihm jetzt auch, ja.
Am Tag im Schnitt, ich denke so 15 bis 20.
Bestes Regal.
Jawoll!
Geht's gut?
Zu deiner Berufserfahrung.
Du warst...
Ich glaube, das hat jeder
schon mal gemacht.
Das ist so typisch.
Ich habe eigentlich gar keinen Bock,
dich das zu fragen, aber der Höflichkeit halber
frage ich dich das jetzt mal.
Das hat jeder schon mal gemacht.
Hey, was geht? Und? Alles klar?
Und in Wirklichkeit denkst du dir allermehr,
es ist scheißegal, wie es dir geht.
Ich werde mit dem Call hier.
Habe ich selbst auch schon
öfters bei mir gemerkt.
Geht's gut?
Zu deiner Berufserfahrung.
Du warst überwiegend Grafiker oder Druckgrafiker.
Du wirst überwiegend
Heidelberg Speedmaster-Maschinen bedienen.
Heidelberg Speedmaster.
Hast du denn zur Firma noch Fragen?
Haben die auch RGB?
...Arbeit oder irgendwie zum Ablauf?
Es ist halt so, dass die Fachkräfte,
die wir einstellen, halt überwiegend
arbeiten nach Deutschland kommen.
Das heißt, die arbeiten auch lieber 10 Stunden mehr
in der Woche oder im Monat.
Von meiner Seite aus ist es mehr als grünes Licht.
Ich würde vorschlagen,
Maschinenbediener 2.500 Euro
netto erste vier Wochen.
Und ab der fünften Woche würde ich
2.650 machen.
Guten Tag dir. Danke, ciao, ciao.
So, war gut.
Guter Mann.
Da merkt man schon, dass er richtig gut war
und so tätig war.
Woran hat er das denn jetzt gemerkt?
Typischer Fall.
Er ist in Polen Druckgrafiker gewesen
oder ist es immer noch mit der eigenen Firma
seit zehn, zwölf Jahren.
Lohnt sich aber finanziell nicht so für ihn,
wie wenn er nach Deutschland kommt
und als Maschinenführer arbeitet.
Ich verdiene 10.500 Euro brutto pro Monat.
Ordentlich.
Netto ca. knappe 6.000 Euro.
Mit Abzügen etc. kriege ich dann ca.
5.500 Euro netto pro Monat.
Da geht was.
Da kannst du dir mal überlegen,
was da teilweise
an Differenz rausgeholt wird
zwischen vermitteltem
und dem,
an dem er vermittelt wird.
Schriebliche Altersvorsorge.
Dann habe ich noch einen Dienstrat,
dass ich über den Arbeitgeber lese
und eine Firmenwagenvereinbarung.
Dann muss ich dringend mal wieder in die Waschanlage.
Die Entfernung zur Arbeit von der Wohnung
ging auch problemlos mit dem E-Bike.
Das nutzen wir im Richtung Sommer auch öfters mal.
Ich habe auch eigentlich
keinen Bezug zu Autos.
Deswegen ja viel Bequemlichkeit dabei.
Ich bin ein bisschen selbstkritisch.
Ich finde auch,
dass das Gehalt, das ich im Monat bekomme ...
Es ist mehr oder weniger
das, was ich auch kriege mit Bonus.
Kommt recht gut hin.
Also wenn guter Bonus dabei ist.
Im Vergleich zu jemandem,
der eine wichtigere Arbeit macht
wie ein Arzt zum Beispiel.
Teilweise auch zu hoch ist.
Oder andererseits, dass die Ärzte
mehr verdienen sollten.
Oder ein Notfallsanitäter.
Ich mag es sehr hell.
Ich finde es ein bisschen beruhigender.
Wir haben einen schönen Balkon,
eine schöne Lage.
Wir haben uns schon ein bisschen was angeschaut,
weil wir uns ein bisschen vergrößern wollen.
Und auf Dauer vielleicht mal uns
einen Hund anschaffen wollen.
Das sollte man sich genau überlegen.
Nachdem wir
bei ihrem Elternhaus zu Hause
relativ großen Bauplatz noch haben,
wird wahrscheinlich dann die Lösung
eher selber bauen sein,
anstatt noch mal ein Haus zu kaufen oder zu mieten.
Tatsächlich ist es ein cooler Anreiz,
sehr gutes Geld zu verdienen.
Weil eigentlich ein relativ großes Hobby von mir
das Reisen ist.
Also ich persönlich mag solche
Deko-Dinger nicht, weil ich finde,
die stehen immer im Weg.
Aber insgesamt finde ich, ist das sehr schick.
Sehr stylisch irgendwie.
Sieht gemütlich aus.
Wahrscheinlich hat es die Frau eingerichtet.
In der heutigen Zeit
war vielleicht ja auch er.
Ich finde es aber echt...
Ist das ein Mikroskop da hinten, Leute?
Ist das ein Mikroskop?
Oder ist das eine Lampe,
die aussieht wie ein Mikroskop?
Eine Espresso-Maschine!
Ich dachte, es sieht aus wie ein Mikroskop.
Ich meine, alternativ
bei mir, ohne Scheiß,
wüsst ihr, wie ich das machen würde,
wenn die bei mir so einen Beitrag filmen würden?
Ich würde aufräumen,
die schönste Ecke zeigen
und den Rest der Wohnung,
da würde das ganze Zeug stehen,
was ich hier vorhin weggeräumt habe,
dass es hier ordentlich aussieht.
So würde ich das machen.
Gutes Geld zu verdienen,
weil eigentlich ein relativ großes Hobby von mir
das Reisen ist.
Ich würde viel dafür leisten.
Ich investiere auch relativ viel Geld
in Fußballspiele.
Das heißt, wir fliegen auch gerne mal
übers Wochenende nach London
und schauen uns da ein Spielchen an oder Ähnliches.
Also mein Job lohnt sich.
Wenn es die nächsten fünf Jahre so weiterläuft wie jetzt,
bin ich sehr glücklich darüber, würde ich sagen.
Würde ich immer noch mitgehen.
Was und und was?
Und 15 Jahre?
Was und?
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Und 15 Jahre?
Ach 15 Jahre!
Würde ich immer noch mitgehen.
Tos, tos, tos, tos, tos, tos, tos, tos, tos.
Also Bock so einen Job zu machen hätte ich nicht.
Aber ich sehe ein,
dass es jemand geben muss, der das macht.
Nicht wie der AliExpress, oder?
Okay.
In letzter Zeit,
wenn ich Videos von Hardware Deals empfohlen bekomme,
dann ist es, wir haben eine CPU
bei AliExpress gekauft.
Dieses Notebook bei AliExpress schockiert uns.
Eine Grafikkarte bei AliExpress.
Ein Komplett-PC bei AliExpress.
Aber zum Thema
Borne...
Echt, macht das LinusTechTips auch so?
Ich gucke wenig LinusTechTips.
Was ist denn eigentlich aus diesem ganzen Beef
rausgekommen bei LinusTechTips?
Die hatten sich doch in den Haaren
mit irgendeinem
anderen Technik-Channel,
der gesagt hat,
die Tests bei LinusTechTips würden
sacken.
Leute, bei mir an der Decke...
Ich muss mal kurz gucken.
An der Decke hängt irgendwas.
Könnte auch nur ein Fussel sein.
Ich glaube, es ist eine Motte.
Ich glaube, es ist nur eine Motte.
Also...
Halb so wild.
Müsste ich jetzt eigentlich mal einsaugen oder
platt machen, aber ich hab grad nix hier.
Ah,
die ist nachher auch noch da.
Okay, da sind sie ja nochmal gut rausgekommen.
Ob das dann wirklich so ist, sei mal dahingestellt.
Aber anscheinend haben sie die Leute beruhigt.
Ah, denn. Okay, was können wir uns denn als nächstes
anzeigen? Zeig mal her, was haben wir denn hier?
Microsoft, ja, Maurice.
Maurice gucke ich immer gern. Was haben wir sonst noch zu Hause?
Passwort-Storage-Tierlist. Das muss ich mir
auch noch angucken, weil irgendwie
hat das eine mit dem anderen wenig zu tun.
YouTube können wir Zicht machen.
Ja, Passwort-Manager-Storage-Tierlist.
Ah, nee,
Chat-GPT hab ich jetzt echt keinen Effe drauf.
Wir gucken jetzt, wir gucken jetzt hier.
Wir gucken jetzt das, was Maurice sagt
zur Blizzard-Activision
und Microsoft-
Übernahme. Die ist ja seit
einer Woche oder zwei Wochen irgendwie durch.
Hast du zwei Katzen oder willst
dir eine zweite zulegen?
Hab ich mir schon öfters überlegt. Also aktuell hab ich eine.
Das hab ich mir schon öfters überlegt. Ich weiß auch,
dass es prinzipiell besser ist, zwei zu haben.
Ich weiß aber nicht, ob es bei Chico besser ist,
zwei zu haben, weil Chico hat prinzipiell
vor allem Schiss, war bisher
ihr Leben lang auch alleine.
Vermutlich zumindest.
Und sobald irgendwie nur was anderes
in der Nähe ist, sitzt sie in der Ecke
und faucht. Also,
ich bin mir da nicht so sicher,
ob das jetzt für Chico eine gute Idee ist.
Ansonsten hätte ich eigentlich
auch ganz gern zwei.
Da können die miteinander ein bisschen Action machen.
Leute, ich muss mal ganz kurz pinkeln.
Vorher kurz.
Peepopupu.
Bin gleich wieder da.
So.
Wieder da.
Ich hab mir grad nochmal den Arm
eingecremt.
Alles klar, Leute.
Dann gucken wir uns
mal das Video an.
Spannend, was Maurice dazu sagt. Also meine
Meinung ist, Microsoft sind auch nicht bekannt
so als die reinen Menschenfreunde.
Also, ob das
wirklich besser wird?
Ich mein, bei Activision ist es schon sehr beschissen gewesen.
Bei Blizzard ging es die
letzten Jahre auch ganz steil bergab.
Bis über Baldur's Gate 3
durch. Nein, bin ich nicht. Ich hab letzter Zeit
wenig, wenig gespielt. Dritter Akt
ist auch etwas, ja,
PP-iger noch.
Microsoft kauft endlich Activision
Blizzard King. Der wohl
beliebteste Mann im Gaming ist damit
bald bei Blizzard raus. Ja, das stimmt. Bobby ist
weg. Und wir alle fragen uns,
wird jetzt endlich alles gut?
Vielleicht.
Also manches. Nicht alles.
Vor allem nicht, wenn ihr Playstation-Spieler
seid. Und deswegen dachte ich mir,
ich will in diesem Video mal alle Fragen
beantworten, die euch
auf der Seele brennen dazu,
was dieser Deal jetzt... Wobei ich nicht
denke, wobei ich echt nicht denke,
dass Call of Duty und sowas Xbox-exklusiv wird.
Weil das ja immer noch eine Abwägung ist.
Das ist eine Abwägung zwischen
wie viel Kohle können wir auf der
Playstation machen, ob diese Exklusivitätsgeschichte
mit der Playstation weitergeht.
Ah, da bin ich... Da hab ich so meine
Zweifel. Aber
das gar nicht mehr dort rausbringen, das ist ja
eine Abwägung zwischen
wie viel Kohle bringt das auf der Playstation
zu releasen versus, ja,
wie viel können wir anderweitig machen
und, sag mal,
was Microsoft was bringt.
Da glaube ich,
dass das Verhältnis aktuell noch nicht so
ausschlaggebend ist. Also ich denke
nicht, dass das der Fall sein wird zur Zeit
schon, dass sie Playstation komplett außen vor lassen.
Aber ganz davon abgesehen ist mir das auch wurscht,
weil Call of Duty geht mir spätestens seit den
ganzen Modern
Warfare Remastered Sachen
echt, also die Rebooted
Sachen, das finde ich so
krass kreativ,
jetzt endgültig, ich werde mir das auch dieses
Jahr nicht kaufen.
Umsätze schon nicht gut.
Eigentlich für uns Gamer. Bedeutet,
und wenn ich irgendwelche vergesse, dann schreibt sie mir in die Kommentare
und dann hole ich das pflichtbewusst
nach. Anfangen möchte ich mit einer
Frage, die euch vielleicht gar nicht auf der Seele brennt,
weil man vielleicht gar nicht weiß, dass man sie sich
noch stellen muss, und zwar
ist der Deal denn jetzt wirklich final
durch? Es sieht so aus, Microsoft
hat ja sogar einen Trailer veröffentlicht, dass das
jetzt passiert. Und ja, das
passiert jetzt. Microsoft
und Activision Blizzard King machen das allerdings
zu einem gewissen Grad noch auf
Verdacht, denn es gibt immer noch
behördlichen Widerstand gegen
den Deal. Kommt jetzt der Master
Chief in Heroes of the Storm, wobei Heroes of the Storm
ist ja im Endeffekt auf
Live-Support so.
Der ihn im Nachhinein
immer noch ungeschehen machen
könnte, was ein bürokratischer
Albtraum wäre, wenn es passieren sollte.
Es gab zwei Behörden im
Wesentlichen, die sich gegen diesen
Deal gestemmt haben, weil sie der Meinung
sind, dass er den Wettbewerb
im Videospielbereich zu stark beeinträchtigt.
Und das war einmal in England
und einmal in den USA.
In England drehte sich das Argument vor allem
um Cloud Gaming und dass Microsoft
zusammen mit Activision Blizzard King
hier zu dominant werden könnte. Dieses Argument
hat viele ehrlich gesagt...
Cloud Gaming? Was ist denn hier eigentlich
mit... Ja gut, ich weiß,
die gibt's nicht mehr. Aber da wurden vor
ein paar Jahren ja auch
so getan, als bricht jetzt das neue Gaming
Zeitalter an. Ich hab mir damals schon gedacht,
so Leute,
entspannt euch mal ein bisschen.
Überrascht, als es
rauskam, mich eingeschlossen,
Cloud Gaming ist aktuell kein
riesiger Markt und...
Angesichts des kompletten
Untergangs von Stadia
wirkte das... Gut, dass du das ansprichst, ja.
lächerlich. Aber
seitdem haben wir geleakte Dokumente
von Microsoft gesehen, die zeigen,
dass sie Cloud Gaming
als eine der wichtigsten
Zukunfts-Säulen ihrer
Gaming-Strategie sehen. Und plötzlich
wirkt das Ganze längst
nicht mehr so weit hergeholt.
Microsoft ist im Bereich Cloud
auch sehr stark aufgestellt. Das hat man
vielleicht gar nicht so auf dem Schirm, wenn man vor allem
die Gaming-News und die Xbox-Sparte
verfolgt. Aber die ist tatsächlich
ein Zwerg innerhalb dieser Firma,
verglichen mit dem Server- und Cloud-Business,
zu dem unter anderem Azure gehört.
Microsoft ist hier ein
Titan. Ja, das stimmt.
Xbox ist wirklich ziemlich mini.
Ich finde, das ist eine gute
Grafik. Und wisst ihr, was man
daran auch dran sieht, ist, dass
Windows bei weitem nicht den
Stellenwert hat, wie das manche Leute sich
denken. Und Office,
jetzt mal hier, Office ist auch
Cloud-Services. Also im Prinzip
sind 55%
Cloud-Services
von Microsoft schon. Bing
könnte man sagen, ist auch in irgendeiner Art und Weise
ein Cloud-Service.
Und das LinkedIn zu Microsoft gehört,
wusste ich gar nicht. Wusste
ihr das?
Deswegen gut positioniert,
falls das im Gaming künftig
immer wichtiger werden sollte, wie es
einige prophezeien. Allerdings hat
die britische Behörde ihren
Einwand zurückgezogen, nachdem
Microsoft mit
mehreren Lösungen zu ihrer
Zufriedenheit dafür gesorgt hat,
dass der Wettbewerb im
Gaming erhalten bleibt. Und diese
Lösungen sind dezent
bizarr, so von außen.
Die Cloud-Gaming-Rechte
für Activision Blizzard
Spiele gingen nämlich an
Ubisoft ausgerechnet.
Also an eine andere Konkurrenz
Firma. Das haben die wahrscheinlich
nur gemacht, dass das Gericht
sagt, ja ist gut.
Geht uns nicht weiter auf den Keks.
Jetzt das Recht hat,
rein theoretisch
Microsoft selbst zu verweigern,
diese Spiele auf ihren
eigenen Cloud-Diensten anzubieten.
Was unwahrscheinlich wirkt,
aber was theoretisch ginge, weil Ubisoft
jetzt die Hoheit über diese Rechte hat.
Das betrifft aber interessanterweise nicht uns
in Europa. Im europäischen Raum
gab es als Zugeständnis an die Europäische
Kommission einen anderen Deal,
der dafür gesorgt hat, dass
tatsächlich jeder Cloud-Anbieter
das Gratisrecht
bekommen soll, für jeden
Nutzer, der ein Spiel in dieser Region
besitzt, es zu streamen.
Also da wurde wirklich
die Cloud-Gaming-Dominanz, die man da befürchtet
hat, massiv aufgeweicht,
um sicherzugehen, dass das
in Ordnung geht. Die
amerikanische Behörde hat sich in ihrer
Argumentation deutlich mehr auf die Konkurrenz
mit Sony konzentriert
und dass die Gefahr besteht, dass
Call of Duty nicht mehr auf der Playstation erscheint
und das den Markt.
Okay, das scheint für die Armies ganz
wichtig zu sein.
Dass man sich da auf einzelne
Gaming-Sachen, auf einzelne
Marken stützt, finde ich
merkwürdig. Zu sehr
beeinträchtigt. Diese Behörde
hat bislang ihre Prozesse
verloren, will aber
diese Entscheidungen anfechten. Das heißt,
es könnte immer noch passieren, dass
sie noch Recht bekommt. Allerdings
halte ich es für sehr unwahrscheinlich,
weil sie hat diese Prozesse
richtig krachend verloren.
Rechtliche Dokumente sind normalerweise
nicht unterhaltsam, aber wie die Richterin
hier auf dem Experten
der Behörde rumgehackt hat,
das muss man sich anschauen, um es
zu glauben. Das ist absurd.
Vielleicht haben sie
den amerikanischen Christian Pfeiffer
geschickt.
... vorgebracht, dass wenn Call of Duty
nicht mehr auf der Playstation erscheint,
dass dann 20 Prozent
aller Spieler sich stattdessen
eine Xbox kaufen würden. Also 20
Prozent aller Spieler, die an Call of Duty
interessiert sind, sich stattdessen eine Xbox
kaufen würden, um es dort zu spielen.
Diese Zahl hat sich der Experte
wohl einfach ausgedacht.
Und das hat die Richterin auch kritisiert
in ihrem Statement. Zu den Beweismaterialien,
die er anführte, hat sie gefragt,
welche Daten stecken dahinter?
Wer hat sie sich ausgedacht?
Professor Lee weiß es nicht.
Und was sagt Professor Lee zur Kritik
an seinen Argumenten?
Nichts. Was bei der Anhörung?
Wieder nichts. Also, wenn die
FTC-Behörde nicht deutlich überzeugender
wird, gehe ich erstmal davon aus,
sie wird sich hier nicht mehr durchsetzen.
Was jetzt erstmal irgendwie
alles witzig ist, aber
natürlich stellt sich die Frage für uns als Gamer,
ist es denn gut für uns,
dass dieser Deal durchging?
Dröseln wir das mal auf anhand
der Frage, die da diskutiert wurde. Heißt
das jetzt mehr Exklusivspiele?
Bei Call of Duty müssen wir uns erstmal
keine Sorgen machen. Es gibt ein
Abkommen mit Sony und
mit Nintendo, dass Call of Duty
auf ihren Plattformen erhalten
bleibt, aber... Moment, es gibt...
Es gibt auf der Switch?
Es gab Modern Warfare auf der Switch?
...aber erstens nur
10 Jahre. Das ist eine lange Zeit.
Moment, ernsthaft?
Hä?
Das war mir nicht klar, dass das auf der
Switch ist. Ist das auch irgendwie
runterskaliert oder so?
Ach, Cloud Gaming über die Switch!
Das ist Cloud Gaming
auf der Switch! Ach
so!
Ich wollt grad sagen, das gab's doch
überhaupt nicht auf der Switch.
Cloud Gaming.
...Zeit jetzt so gesehen, aber ist
auch irgendwann vorbei und zweitens auch
nur Call of Duty. Und Microsoft
hat zuletzt mit Starfield und Redfall
gezeigt, dass sie durchaus gewillt
sind, die Spiele aus ihren eigenen
Studios, selbst ganz große Blockbuster
wie Starfield, die wahrscheinlich auf der
Playstation eine Menge Geld eingebracht hätten,
von der Playstation abzuziehen.
Und das, obwohl sie
2021 vor dem
Bethesda-Kauf, der ja auch durch
diese gleichen Behörden musste, noch
argumentiert haben, wir haben keinen
Anreiz, Zenimax-Spiele
auf Konkurrenzkonsolen einzuschränken.
Inzwischen wissen wir,
auch Elder Scrolls 6 kommt nicht auf
die Playstation und Microsoft hat Bethesda
sogar gezielt gekauft, damit
Sony diese Spiele nicht exklusiv bekommt.
Ich gehe also davon aus, wir werden
mittel- bis langfristig
mehr Exklusives sehen, die nicht
auf der Playstation erscheinen.
Ey, solange die im Game Pass
und für PC verfügbar sind, juckt mich das
nicht. Aber natürlich, für Playstation-Spieler
schon problematisch. Auch große
Namen betreffen, wie eben zum Beispiel
Elder Scrolls oder vielleicht in der Zukunft
auch Diablo und dergleichen.
Und Exklusives, muss man einfach so direkt
sagen, sind immer blöd
für Spieler. Ich bin überhaupt kein Fan
davon, lasst die Leute da spielen, wo sie
wollen. Gerade das ist ja etwas, was sich Microsoft
sogar offiziell auf die Flagge
schreibt. Und man muss der Fans halber sagen,
ich mag Microsoft-Exklusives lieber
als Sony-Exklusives, weil sie
immerhin direkt auf den PC kommen. Und
nicht erst Jahre später, weil Sony jetzt
auch mal gemerkt hat, dass PC-Gamer
Bock auf geile Spiele haben und bereit
sind, dafür Geld zu zahlen. Ja. Und es gibt
auch Positives, was die Verfügbarkeit
von Spielen angeht. Ich hätte ja
echt gerne die ersten
drei Uncharted-Games auf dem PC.
Die würde ich gerne mal wieder spielen.
Mit dem Emulator geht
es teilweise, aber Uncharted
ist eines der, sagen wir mal, schwierigsten
Spiele zu emulieren. Spiele jetzt in den
Game Pass kommen. Erst 2024
zwar, aber trotzdem. Und auch sonst
zu mehr Anbietern, wie zum Beispiel
bizarrerweise Ubisoft.
Das bringt uns zur nächsten Frage.
Jetzt, wo Microsoft Activision
Blizzard King gekauft hat,
werden die Spiele denn besser
dadurch? Der CEO
Bobby Kotick soll schon Ende
2023 gehen. Wir erinnern uns,
das ist der Mann,
der allen
Spaß aus der Videospielentwicklung
nehmen wollte und sich ganz
gut Mühe gegeben hat, dieses Ziel
zu erreichen. Unter Kotick ist
vor allem Blizzard gieriger und
verlogener geworden. Das stimmt. Eine Firma,
die ihre Spiele aggressiver monetarisiert,
siehe Diablo Immortal, und
keine Scheu hat, ihren Kunden
rundheraus ins Licht zu lügen.
... das ist rein BWL
gedöhnt und die haben gar nichts miteinander zu
tun. Ich hab mir damals schon gedacht, naja,
also das wächst immer weiter
zusammen, da gibt's ein Management oben drüber,
gemeinsame Strategie. Aber wollten
mir die Leute damals erzählen, kompletter Blödsinn.
Und man hat jetzt gesehen, ganz so kompletter Blödsinn war es dann
doch nicht. ... siehe
Warcraft 3 Reforged. Und dann
auch überhaupt ... Deforged, ja.
... nicht bestrebt ist, solche Fehltritte
wieder gut zu machen. Mitarbeiter werden
derweil so schlecht behandelt, dass viele
führende Blizzard-Köpfe abgehauen sind und
die Verbliebenen es immer schwerer haben,
unter diesen Bedingungen gute Spiele
zu machen. Es ist ziemlich
bemerkenswert, wie viele Mitarbeiter
sich öffentlich auf Twitter über die
Unternehmenskultur und auch
konkret über Bobby Kotick ihren
Oberboss auskotzen. Das
muss ja ziemlich weit gehen, dass man sich
das überhaupt traut und dass man das Gefühl hat,
man hat keine andere Wahl als das. Ja,
vor allem musst du damit rechnen, dass der dich dann morgen
dafür rausschmeißt und trotzdem ist den Leuten egal.
Da muss der Frust schon echt tief sitzen.
Die Firma hat sogar öffentlich in
Investorenberichten zugegeben, sie
hat einen schlechten Ruf als
Arbeitsplatz und hat daher Probleme,
gute Leute zu finden und zu halten, was
notwendig ist, um mit der Konkurrenz
Schritt zu machen. Die haben ja auch
alles dafür getan, einen schlechten Ruf zu haben.
Nicht nur was die Games angeht,
wir erinnern uns dran, was bei Blizzard die letzten
Jahre über noch gelaufen ist.
Ich sag nur McCree. Es ist auch
naiv zu glauben, dass sowas
an einem Mann hängt und dass
das jetzt alles magisch wieder gut
wird. Aber das hat,
ohne Scheiß, das hat trotzdem Auswirkungen,
je nachdem, wie die Weichen
gestellt werden und was für eine Marschrichtung
vom oberen Management da kommt. Das hat enorm
viel Einfluss drauf. Natürlich wird
es nicht von heute auf morgen, nur weil die gekauft werden,
alles anders werden.
Das ist schon klar.
Da werden auch einige Leute ausgetauscht werden müssen,
sodass die neue Vision, wenn es denn eine neue gibt,
da ordentlich
vertreten wird. Und ob die dann besser ist
für uns als Spieler als die bisherige,
das muss ich noch zeigen. Oder vielleicht
auch ein paar seiner Mitbosse
gehen. Unter anderem natürlich, weil auch
viel Schaden einfach schon angerichtet ist.
Es sind ja schon viele gute Leute gegangen.
Auch wenn manche jetzt wieder zurückkommen, wie Chris Madsen
zum Beispiel. Ach,
der ist wieder da? Der ist doch quasi in
Rente quasi gegangen
vor ein paar Jahren.
Solche Probleme sind ja etwas
tiefer verwurzelt in einer Firmenkultur.
Auch wenn man immer wieder gesehen hat, es gibt
bei... Das ist unter anderem der, der auch viele,
wenn ihr in Warcraft 3 gespielt habt,
viele der Sounds damals noch selbst
eingesprochen hat. Der ist ja schon ewig
dabei.
Auch Leute, die da hinkämpfen.
Also, wer weiß. Und man muss auch
dazu sagen, auch Microsoft ist kein
perfekter Arbeitgeber. Auch die
haben sich eingereiht in die Riege
der Arbeitgeber, die gerade massiv
Stellen abbauen. Sie haben 2023
im Januar 10.000 Leute gefeuert.
Aber sie könnten trotzdem
Besserung erwirken. Denn es
gibt auch Anzeichen, dass
es unter Microsoft vielleicht
ein wenig Licht am Ende des Tunnels geben
könnte. Zum Beispiel hat sich Microsoft festgelegt,
nicht gegen Gewerkschaften bei
Activision Blizzard King vorzugehen.
Wohingegen Bobby Kotick der Meinung war.
Es gab bei der Firma sowieso nie Probleme
mit der Arbeitskultur. Und das
alles ist nur eine Schmutzkampagne
von einer aggressiven
Arbeiterbewegung, die Firma
zu destabilisieren.
Wisst ihr, was
an diesen Meldungen
so das
ja, das Werkwürdige ist?
Das ist durchaus möglich, dass der
das wirklich denkt.
Es gibt ja immer so das Ding so
okay, wir machen das jetzt, weil es eine offizielle Pressemeldung
ist. Es ist durchaus möglich,
dass der das wirklich denkt.
Diese Arbeiterbewegung
Das Bizarre, würde Maurice sagen.
Es ist durchaus möglich,
dass der das wirklich denkt.
Firma zu destabilisieren.
Es sprechen durchaus Sachen für
Microsoft als Arbeitgeber. Ich habe mit mehreren
Entwicklern im Laufe der Jahre geredet, die
sehr glücklich dort waren
und darüber waren, Teil von Microsoft zu sein.
Zum Beispiel Brian Fargo, der sich eigentlich
schon zur Ruhe setzen wollte und dann meinte,
der Microsoft-Kauf war der Grund, warum er weiter
Spiele machen will. Unter anderem, weil
er unter deren Schirmherrschaft und
ganz klar direkt gesagt, mit deren Geld
Wasteland 3 zu einem noch viel cooleren Spiel
machen konnte und Wasteland 3 war ein
verdammt gutes Rollenspiel. Außerdem
erlaubt Microsoft sehr kreative
experimentelle Spiele, wie zum Beispiel
Pentiment, wo man sich nicht
vorstellen kann, dass ein
Schriftrollenspiel im
Mittelalter in einer bayerischen
Stadt, dass das unter
Activision Blizzard möglich gewesen wäre.
Wo bringt das denn die
finanziellen Sachen ein,
die wir brauchen? Wo sind die Mikrotransaktionen?
Also es besteht zumindest
Hoffnung, dass unter Microsoft
die Dinge ein wenig nach oben gehen
wieder für Activision Blizzard und wie gesagt
vor allem für Blizzard. Also
kriegen wir unter Microsoft
wieder Blizzard-Spiele. Wisst ihr, wie interessant
das ist das aller aller
erste, oder das ist das
World of Warcraft Original Classic
Intro Cinematic.
Wie gut das damals schon ausgesehen hat, ne?
Wie früher.
Microsoft hat ja durchaus
Kinderfilme, das konnten die schon immer.
Das zeigt, dass sie Bock drauf haben und sich darauf
verstehen, alte Klassiker
sogar ganz konkret im Oldschool
RTS-Bereich wieder aufleben zu lassen.
Age of Empires 2
floriert unter der Schirmherrschaft von Microsoft
wie lange davor nicht mehr und wie
wir es uns für all die anderen
großen Strategie-Franchises dieser Zeit
nur wünschen können.
Und hey, in diesem Trailer,
den sie gezeigt haben, ist auch
StarCraft drin, der Trailer
zu dieser Firmenzusammenkunft.
Allerdings sprechen auch
hier wieder Punkte dagegen. Age of Empires 4
war allem Anschein nach
nicht ganz der Erfolg
den sich Microsoft vermutlich erhofft hat.
Würde ich zumindest vermuten.
Also Age of Empires 4, ich hab's nicht gespielt.
Also nicht aktiv gespielt.
Ich hab aber auf Twitch öfters
mal geguckt. Das hatte einen immensen
Hype ursprünglich.
Gerade auch, was die
E-Sport-Szene angibt. Da gab es wirklich an jeder Ecke
Turniere und Streamer und sonst was.
Ich gucke ja ganz gerne bei Krabby
öfters so, wenn es um Strategie-Spiele geht.
Und
die haben wohl das gleiche Problem wie viele
andere Entwickler gehabt.
Das Spiel war draußen
und dann hat sich halt die ganzen Probleme
rausgestellt, die es gab.
Multiplayer-technisch. Und es hat
ewig gedauert
bis irgendwelche Sachen balanced
wurden, gepatcht wurden, auch einfach kaputte Sachen
angepasst wurden. Ewig.
Mittlerweile sind die meisten
Leute weg davon.
Und ich glaube, Turniere gibt's auch
immer weniger.
Und ob es überhaupt noch
Orgas gibt, die
Age of Empires 4-Spieler ...
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist echt
bisschen zu lang im Sande verlaufen
nach Release.
Es wird weiterentwickelt.
Es war immer schon ein tolles Spiel.
Es hatte zu Release leider einige Probleme,
die zu spät angegangen wurden.
Und es hat enttäuscht auf der Singleplayer-Kampagnenfront.
Aber es ist ein
cooles RTS. Und es ist schade,
dass es dann ein wenig untergegangen
ist nach einem starken Start.
Und ich könnte mir halt vorstellen, dass das
bei Microsoft, sag ich mal, die Lust auf
Oldschool-RTS-Marken-Revivals
wieder ein wenig abkühlen hat lassen.
Wir haben auch schon lange nichts mehr von Age of Mythology Retold
gehört, was ich unbedingt
haben will. Microsoft, wann?
Das war ehrlich gesagt nicht meins.
Aber ja, es ist nicht garantiert,
dass Microsoft das Age-2-Schema
und das auf
Blizzard-RTS-Franchises
anwenden wird und die dann
fortführen wird. Aber es ist zumindest
wahrscheinlicher, als es davor war.
Weil davor haben wir ja gemerkt,
haben sie offensichtlich überhaupt keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Siehe Warcraft 3 Reforged.
Es ist zumindest nicht schlimmer geworden.
Es gibt mehr Hoffnung als vorher.
Das ist doch heutzutage auch schon was,
worüber man sich freuen muss. Deswegen das Fazit.
Also was
sich an Warcraft 3
Reforged von
wenn man
sich jetzt Videos anguckt, die richtig
gute Warcraft-3-Spiele
drüber gemacht haben, eines der Hauptkritikpunkte
ist, dass man
keine Übersicht mehr hat.
Dass die Silhouette
der Units nicht richtig passt.
Dass die
ganze, wie soll man sagen,
die ganze Crispness,
sodass man immer jederzeit erkennt,
was wie wo passiert.
Auch im Getümmel, dass das mit
den Reforged-Models und der Reforged-
Grafik nicht gegeben ist.
Neben ganz vielen
anderen Sachen, die versprochen wurden und weggelassen wurden.
Deswegen spielt auch kaum
einer der ehemaligen
Warcraft-3-Pros, weiß nicht, ob es heute noch
gibt. Ja doch, in China gibt es immer noch welche.
Keiner eigentlich mit
Reforged-Grafiks.
Soft Activision Blizzard
King-Deal, gut fürs Gaming.
Ich persönlich freue mich darüber.
Sag ich so direkt. Einfach nur
wegen Blizzard. Es ist meiner Meinung nach die beste
Chance, die wir haben, dass
sich bei Blizzard was bessert. Die Chance ist
allemal höher, als wenn der Deal nicht
durchgegangen wäre und die Firma unter
Kotic verblieben wäre. Das klingt sinnvoll, was er sagt.
Nein, Microsoft ist keineswegs...
Würde ich auch so unterschreiben.
Da besteht zumindest jetzt die
Chance, dass sich da was tut.
...unfehlbar.
Gerade neulich haben sie mit Redfall ordentlich daneben
gelangt. Aber sie haben auch
viel Gutes gemacht.
Es gibt hier allerdings einen breiteren
Punkt, der noch zu bedenken ist und der mir Sorgen
macht. Wie gesagt, diesen konkreten
Deal finde ich aus purem
Eigennutz... Okay, jetzt kommt
er findet es nicht gut, dass so viel zentriert
ist bei vielen großen
Unternehmen. Ich glaube, dass das jetzt
kommt. Dass es zu
wenige nur noch gibt.
Wer ein besseres Blizzard will, gut.
Er ist aber auch ein weiterer Schritt im
Trend der stetigen Konsolidierung
im Gaming. Das meine ist, dass
sich Gaming unter weniger und
weniger immer größeren Firmen
zusammenfindet. Und wenn
diese Firmen mal Probleme
haben oder sich entscheiden,
ihre Businessstrategie jetzt
ein wenig mehr auf rücksichtsloses Geld machen
zu trimmen, dann leiden Spieler
wie Entwickler darunter. Wir sehen das gerade
bei der Embracer Group, zu denen auch
ich gehört, bei denen ein 2 Mrd.
Deal mit einer saudi-arabischen
Firma geplatzt ist und jetzt
geht der Kahlschlag durch all deren
Studios und es werden bergeweise
Entwickler gefeuert, die absolut nichts dafür können,
dass der Chef ihres Chefs, ihres
Chefs auf einen Deal spekuliert
hat, der am Ende nicht geklappt hat.
Das, ne...
Keck wie Business. Solche
Dinge können immer wieder passieren.
Und das sehe ich mit
Sorge. Siehe auch, wie gesagt, andere
Firmen, wie Tencent, wie natürlich
auch Sony. Das Gaming geht immer mehr
in diese Richtung und das kann
nicht nur positive Effekte
für den Endkunden haben.
Am Ende ist auch Microsoft eine Firma im
Konkurrenzkampf. Sie sind nicht die
Guten, die jetzt das böse Sony... Das ist das, was ich
am Anfang auch gemeint hab. Das sind ja nicht alles
Menschenfreunde jetzt über Nacht bei Microsoft, so
oh ja, jetzt wird alles gut.
Aber die Chance darauf, dass sich da bei
Blizzard was ändert, das finde ich
ist schon ein guter Punkt. Liegt haben,
um einen Deal aus purer
Selbstlosigkeit zum Wohle der Spieler
durchzubringen. Man sollte an dieser Stelle
auch erwähnen, dass zu Activision Blizzard
ja auch noch King gehört.
Die Macher von Candy Crush
und einer der erfolgreichsten
Mobilespielentwickler der Welt.
Wir Core-Gamer haben das vielleicht gar
nicht so auf dem Schirm, wenn wir über diese Firma
reden, weil es uns halt mehr
um Blizzard oder Call of Duty je nach
Spielegeschmack geht. Aber King ist größer
als Blizzard und dürfte für Microsoft
sogar einer der wichtigsten
strategischen Gründe für diesen Kauf
gewesen sein. Denn damit
haben sie plötzlich ein enorm
mächtiges Standbein im
gräßlichen, unsäglichen
Mobile-Spielemarkt.
Mehr als
eins sogar, denn Activision
und Blizzard haben sich ja ebenfalls mehr
und mehr auf diesen Markt konzentriert
in den letzten Jahren. Ja, Leute, habt ihr
keine Phones, ja? Und ja, wir
freuen uns ja immer, wenn
mehr Firmen mehr Profite
mit
Mobile-Spielchen erzielen, nicht wahr?
Und auch das ist
eine Konsequenz dieses Deals.
Aber es könnte
doch einiges Gutes daraus erwachsen
in der bestmöglichen
Zeitlinie. In der schlechtmöglichsten
Zeitlinie wäre Bobby Kotick
jetzt von Activision Blizzard weg
und wäre der neue CEO von Playstation
geworden. Da ist ja neulich ein
Wechsel stattgefunden. Aber zum Glück
wir leben immerhin schon mal nicht in dieser
schlechtmöglichsten Zeitlinie. Vielleicht
leben wir also in einer, in der
was Gutes draus erwächst.
Also mich würd's nicht wundern, wenn
Bobby in irgendeiner Position
demnächst wieder aufploppt.
Wie erfolgreich war
Diablo Immortal eigentlich?
Also nach allem dem, was ich mitbekommen hab,
wohl enorm erfolgreich.
Im Auge behalten, mit einem gespannten
und einem Arm anfaschen Auge.
Ich würde mich freuen, wenn ihr mir
auch auf Twitch folgt. Twitch Maurice Weber.
Dort werde ich auch live
weiterhin über alle Entwicklungen berichten
und das geht da manchmal noch etwas flotter, als
hier auf YouTube, wo man sich ja natürlich ein wenig
Zeit nehmen will, ein Video mit Substanz
zurechtzulegen zu diesen Themen.
Ich hoffe, das ist mir in dem Fall gelungen.
Ich hoffe, es hat euch... Alles gut.
Maurice, seine Videos kann es nicht immer gut geben.
Immer Pog.
Hyper Pog. Das Game war
Trash. Ja. Oh, was haben wir denn
hier sonst noch? Passwort, das muss ich mir jetzt
angucken. Ich weiß nicht, was das Video
mir sagen soll, aber
ich finde, die Sachen haben alle nichts großartig
miteinander zu tun. Also sind unterschiedliche
Sachen, die man entweder zusammen oder
exklusiv verwenden kann.
Weil Hashing ist keine Encryption
und... Mal gucken. Vielleicht
taugt das Video auch nix, dann machen wir aus, aber
kann ich auch meinen Senf zugeben.
Hast du
das hier gesehen? Ne.
Revenge? Das klingt wie diese...
wie die Android-App,
mit der man früher YouTube
als Alternativ-Klient gucken konnte.
Dütütü.
Dütü.
Das ist mein Verband am
Arm. Richtig, man. Nudel mit Lachs?
Heute nicht. Heute gibt es
keine Nudel mit Lachs.
Ihr könnt ja mal raten, was meint ihr, wenn es heute
keine Nudel mit Lachs gibt?
Was gibt's dann?
Gibt ja nicht so viele Möglichkeiten.
Bolognese.
Richtig.
Nudeln mit Tomatensauce und Hackfleisch. Korrekt. So sieht's aus.
Ich seh schon, ihr wisst Bescheid, was es bei mir Samstags zu essen gibt. So, Pass-Passwords. Zeig mal her, Storing.
Okay.
Ja, Plaintext-Passwörter in Plaintext-Storen ist immer
heilig, Pepega.
Laut genug? Okay, das Wörste ist wahrscheinlich Plaintext.
Sie lauter.
Plaintext.
Ja, das ist in der Regel für, sagen wir mal, so Debug- und Testing-Sachen kann man das mal machen, wenn man genau wissen will, was passiert, aber es sollte nie in einem fertigen Bild landen und schon gar nicht in irgendeiner Production-Database, sonst wie was im Klartext.
Ja, das ist schlechte Idee.
Hacker.
Ah.
Macht man aber in der Regel nicht so?
Am besten ist, wenn die Passwörter überhaupt nicht in irgendeiner Art und Weise in der Datenbank stehen. So machst du es eigentlich auch.
Also wenn es ordentlich gemacht ist, wirst du keine Passwörter, sowohl Plaintext als auch Encrypted in der Datenbank finden.
Oder überhaupt nicht auf Server-Seite.
Das Passwort verlässt am besten nie den Client, beziehungsweise, ja, nicht übertragen. Einfach keine Passwörter nutzen.
Ja, genau.
Ja, das ist das, was ich meine.
Nein.
Ja.
Ja, genau.
Ja, das ist das, was ich meine.
Nein.
Ja.
1,2,3,4,5,6 als MD5
Und jetzt machen wir mal
1,2,3,4,5
Was fällt euch
zwischen diesen beiden Hashes auf?
Oder was heißt das?
Blöd gestellte Frage
Ihr seht den Input
Der Input hat sich nur hier an einem Zeichen verändert
Gleiche Länge
Richtig
Das ist eines
Aber, und das ist ganz wichtig für eine gute Hash-Funktion
Der Output
sieht auch bei kleinem Change
im Input komplett anders aus
Das ist der
eigentliche Punkt
Also du darfst quasi keine Rückschlüsse ziehen können
aus dem Input zu dem Output
Wenn jetzt beispielsweise
sich hier nur ein bisschen was geändert hätte
wenn sich der Input ein bisschen ändert
dann muss es ja irgendeinen Zusammenhang geben zwischen den beiden Inputs
Das heißt bei einer guten Hash-Funktion
ist egal
wie klein die Änderung ist
Im Input
der Output immer komplett random
anders
Jetzt ist aber natürlich auch so ein Ding
was man sich überlegen kann
Wenn man sich hier jetzt mal
das Passwort anguckt
1,2,3,4,5,6
Wie lang kann der
Ihr seht, das ist immer gleich lang
der Hash hier
Wir nehmen mal wie gesagt MD5
Was mache ich denn hier?
Aber ist letztendlich auch wurscht
Ihr seht, der Output
ist immer gleich lang
Und jetzt überlegt mal Chat
Wie lang kann der Input sein?
Wie groß kann der Input werden?
Also Output wissen wir
Der Output ist immer gleich lang
Egal was man reinsteckt
Der Input kann, naja, sagen wir mal
unendlich in Anführungszeichen
weil in irgendeiner Art und Weise
ist es dann doch durch RAM
aber sagen wir mal
nahezu
nahezu unbegrenzt
Ich dürfte aber jetzt schon
auffallen, wenn ich das hier reinstecke
Das ist länger
als der Output
Das heißt im Endeffekt, der Output ist immer gleich lang
Aber egal
wie der Input variiert
der Output ist immer gleich lang
Das heißt
im Umkehrschluss jetzt auch
Hier hat man ja
eine begrenzte Anzahl an Zeichen
um den Hashtag zu stellen
Jetzt habe ich nochmal eine Frage
an euch Chat
Ist es denn möglich
dass ich mit unterschiedlichem
Input
mit zwei unterschiedlichen
Inputs den gleichen Output bekomme?
Ja, ist möglich, ne?
Ist ja im Prinzip auch
irgendwie logisch. Das ist bei allen Hashtags so
Ne, ne, das ist nicht nur
bei MD5 so, das ist bei allen Hashtags so
Nein, nein, nein, das ist bei Chart 256
ganz genauso. Bei Chart 256
ist es
ein bisschen unwahrscheinlicher
Ein bisschen unwahrscheinlicher ist gut
Sagen wir mal so
Teilchen im Universum
seit 14 Milliarden Jahren
unwahrscheinlicher, also ich sehe viel
unwahrscheinlicher, aber es ist etwas unwahrscheinlicher
als bei MD5
Aber nachdem du ja immer
nahezu unbegrenzten
Zeichenvorrat als Input
benutzen kannst und das
zusammenfassen musst, was quasi
durch den Fleischwolf drehen musst in was, was immer
fix gleich lang ist
kann es bei allen
Hashing-Varianten
Kollisionen geben
Und jetzt kommt die Preisfrage
Wie viel mögliche
Also gehen wir mal davon aus, du kannst unendlich viel Input
reinpacken. Wie viele
Kollisionen kann es denn geben?
Und da müssen wir jetzt wirklich
den Florian anhauen, ob das stimmt, was ich erzähle
Ich würde auch sagen, es gibt
potenziell bei jedem Hashing-Algorithmus
unendlich viele Kollisionen
Das Gute ist, dass es zwar
theoretisch unendlich viele gibt
aber es enorm
unwahrscheinlich ist, eine zu finden
Das klingt jetzt erstmal widersprüchlich
Es gibt
unendlich viele Kollisionen, theoretisch
mögliche Kollisionen, aber trotzdem
ist glaube ich für Chart
256 noch keine
einzige
Kollision bekannt
Ich glaube es gibt für Chart
256 noch nicht eine einzige
Kollision, die
bisher gefunden wurde
Also man sieht, auch wenn es theoretisch
unendlich viele gibt, praktisch gesehen
ist es doch sehr unwahrscheinlich, eine zu finden
Soviel sogar als
kurzer Exkurs dazu
Leitet sich
das Sol vom ursprünglichen Plaintext-Input ab?
Naja, je nachdem
wie man es nimmt
Der Salt ist nicht Bestandteil von deinem
Passwort, aber der Salt kommt im
Plaintext mit dabei
Ja, unendliche Inputs ist
aufgrund von RAM und so, das habe ich ja gesagt, ist eigentlich
gar nicht möglich, aber
gehen wir mal theoretisch davon aus
Du musst aber beim Salt natürlich
das Plaintext-Passwort und dein Plaintext-Salt
zusammen in die Hashing-Funktion
stecken. Ja, aber das kommt
wahrscheinlich jetzt gleich
Bekannte Kollisionen für MD5? Ja, da gibt es
Fünfte. Da gibt es einige
Da gibt es tatsächlich ein paar
Bekannte Kollisionen
bei MD5
Aber
das meiste ist ein bisschen suboptimal
um es auf dem
um es auf dem Terminal
zu zeigen, weil
viele der Kollisionen sind
entweder sehr lang oder halt
ja, nicht unbedingt gerade
gut in ASCII darstellbar
oder in Zeichen
darstellbar. Das sind dann irgendwelche
Random-Hex-Dinger
Zweifelsfall
Also, ich glaube nicht, dass es
MD5-Kollisionen
gibt, wo die gut lesbar
sind. Ja, dass man jetzt
sagen würde, Hallo, Chat
und blub123
entspricht dem gleich. Genau!
Sowas hier in der Richtung kennt man als Kollision
Das ist halt, naja
ein bisschen unhandlich
Aber MD5
gibt es bekannte Kollisionen. Ich glaube,
für Char 206
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob es
überhaupt für Char überhaupt
was gibt. Okay
Okay, für die Alter, aber ich glaube, für da gibt es
da gibt es noch keine
Es ist aber halt auch enorm
Es ist auch wirklich enorm
unwahrscheinlich
Es sei denn, und das darf man ja nie außer
Acht lassen, es sei denn, jemand
findet Schwächen im Hashing-
Algorithmus. Er findet beispielsweise
doch Zusammenhänge zwischen
Input und dem, was rauskommt. Dann
ist das was anderes, aber wenn wir mal
davon ausgehen, dass der Hashing-
Algorithmus selbst das
macht, was er machen soll
How to get arrested in 30 minutes
Moncatos Video
Man weiß ja nie hier, wie
Chibait-Titel
Das wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen
Ja, aber wenn man davon ausgeht, dass das funktioniert, ist es doch
sehr, sehr, sehr
unwahrscheinlich
dass da eine gefunden wird
Okay
Ich kann euch nicht sagen, wie unwahrscheinlich
aber wir reden hier nicht
in unwahrscheinlich, wie
im Fahrstuhl abzustürzen, sondern
wir reden hier von unwahrscheinlich
in Größenordnung, wo mir gar kein
Beispiel für einfällt
Ja, das ist auch noch ein Punkt
Das ist ein bisschen wie finde in der Klasse
Leute, die zu deinem Geburtstag
auch Geburtstag haben versus
finde zwei Leute in der Klasse, die zum gleichen Zeitpunkt
Geburtstag haben. Ja, das ist natürlich nochmal was anderes
Das ist theoretisch
einfacher, quasi
ja, finde zwei Hashes
die den gemeinsamen
Input, die den
gemeinsamen Hash ergeben oder finde
einen weiteren Input zu meinem vorgegebenen
Input, der den gleichen Hash ergibt
Das ist noch
mal was ganz anderes
Mir fällt wirklich keine
Unwahrscheinlichkeitsvergleich ein
Wie unwahrscheinlich das ist
Ich weiß es jetzt nicht in Zahlen, aber
eine Kollision in Chart 256 zu finden
ist wahrscheinlich so unwahrscheinlich, wie
keine Ahnung, dass
in den letzten
14 Milliarden Jahren
es euch schon
ein anderes Mal gab auf irgendeinem anderen
Planet, so nach dem Motto. Es ist enorm
unwahrscheinlich
Nein, das ist deutlich
höher die Chance
das auf den Kopf zu bekommen
als eine Chart-256-Kollision zu finden
Also, weiter, weiter
Video gucken
Das ist ja das, was ich auch
gerade gezeigt habe
Generiert ein kleines Fingerprint oder Hash
und steuert es anstatt
dem eigentlichen Passwort
Login
Ja
So macht man das, wenn man
das gescheit speichern möchte, korrekt
Keine Passwörter auf Serverseite
Okay
Bevor wir weiter gucken
Mal gucken, wer von euch
aufgepasst hat, nicht bei meinem
jetzt, sondern so, vielleicht hattet ihr das mal
in der Schule oder sonst wo
Was ist denn eines der Angriffsszenarien
dafür? Gehen wir mal von aus
Wir haben jetzt hier unser
Passwort
MD5-Sum
Ja, richtig, der Chat weiß schon Bescheid
Also, ich glaube, hier
ist es relativ offensichtlich, was ein
Schwachpunkt davon ist
Und zwar, wenn ihr das hier
findet, mal angenommen, ihr bekommt einen
Datenbankdump
und ihr findet diesen Hash
in der Datenbank, dann könnt ihr
relativ sicher sein
dass im Vorfeld schon
jemand mal so übliche Passwörter
durchprobiert hat, was die für
Hashes ergeben und die abgespeichert
hat, d.h. ihr könnt dann einfach eine
Reverse Lookup im Endeffekt machen
Ihr habt dann ein Dictionary, wo drinnen steht
dieser Input Hash
ist dieses Passwort oder
du kannst halt nachgucken
und bei so einfachen Sachen kannst du davon ausgehen
dass für alle gängigen
Hashing-Algorithmen schon
Tabellen existieren
wo du nachgucken kannst, welcher
Hash rauskommt. D.h. man
sieht auch daran, es ist nicht unwichtig
ein ordentliches Passwort
zu wählen
Das ersetzt das nicht
Also wenn man im Vorfeld
das schon
ein riesen Dictionary hat
aus vorberechneten
Hashes, dann
ist das ein Problem
Und das ist übrigens auch bei
Ihr seht ja, das ist auch bei SHA256
also rein, dass die einen
sicheren Hashing-Algorithmus verwenden
macht euer unsicheres Passwort nicht
sicherer, weil da könnt ihr Gift drauf
nehmen, dass solche Tabellen
für das ganze Reverse
zu lookuppen
dass das auch
für alle gängigen Hashing-Algorithmen
existiert
Werden Usernamen dann auch gehashed?
Das ist sicherlich eine Implementierungsfrage
Insult mit zu hashen ist deutlich
sinniger
Was Insult bringt, ist, dass du nicht vorberechnen kannst
Das ist das, was Insult bringt
Da sage ich aber gleich was dazu
Wenn der im Video dazu kommt
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen hat es gerade
mein Browser zerlegt
oder kam sogar
genau wieder an der Stelle, wo ich aufgehört habe
Alles klar
Hashing klingt momentan ein bisschen magisch
Wie kann Hashing jemanden verhindern
den original Passwort vom
Output-Hash zu wiederholen? Und wie kann es
zwei Stringe verhindern, dass sie zum selben Passwort
gehen und jemanden mit dem falschen Passwort
loggen lassen?
Hashing
Kein Hashing-Algorithmus
ist kollisionsfrei
Hashing
Das ist ein gutes Beispiel. Das ist echt ein gutes Beispiel.
Wie gesagt, die Haschfunktion vermischt die Daten in einer Art und Weise, dass sogar kleine Veränderungen in der Input
in total unterschiedlichen Haschen erfolgen.
Als Ergebnis, für gute Haschfunktionen gibt es keinen öffentlichen Weg, zwei Stränge zu generieren,
deren Hasche zusammenkommen, ohne einfach viele, viele, viele Stränge zu probieren.
Kein Glück mit diesen 10.
Diese Eigenschaft nennt sich Kollisionresistenz.
Die richtige Haschfunktion zu wählen, ist wichtig.
Wir dachten früher, dass ältere Haschfunktionen, die ihr vielleicht gehört habt,
wie MD5 und SHA1, Kollisionresistenz hatten,
aber die Kryptografie hat sich weiterentwickelt und sie wurden unsicher.
Zum Beispiel, ca. ein Jahrhundert her, haben Rechercherer eine Methode eröffnet, um eine Kollision zu generieren.
Zwei Stränge, die den gleichen MD5-Hasch haben,
die ihr in etwa einen Sekunden auf eurem Laptop laufen könnt.
Also haben wir auf stärkere Haschfunktionen gewechselt, wie SHA2,
die ich in diesem Video benutzt habe.
Also haben wir auf einen MD5-Hasch gewechselt,
den ihr in etwa einen Sekunden auf eurem Laptop laufen könnt.
Zum Beispiel, ca. ein Jahrhundert her, haben Rechercherer eine Methode eröffnet,
um eine Kollision zu generieren.
Zwei Stränge, die den gleichen MD5-Hasch haben,
die ihr in etwa einen Sekunden auf eurem Laptop laufen könnt.
Finde mal zwei Stränge, die den gleichen Haschwert erzeugen.
Ist das deutlich einfacher, als eine Haschkollision zu finden,
zu einem Wert, den du vorgibst.
Das ist ähnlich, wie wenn du eine Klasse hast mit 28 Schülern.
Und du suchst jemand in der Klasse, der am gleichen Tag Geburtstag hat wie du.
Die Chance ist relativ gering.
Suchst du allerdings zwei Leute, die an deinem Tag Geburtstag haben,
sondern suchst du in der Klasse einfach nur zwei Leute,
die am gleichen Tag Geburtstag haben,
ist die Chance viel, viel höher.
Und die Chance ist deutlich höher, als man denkt.
Was denkt ihr denn, wenn ihr eine Klasse habt mit 28 Leuten drin,
wie hoch die Chance ist, dass zwei Leute am gleichen Geburtstag haben?
60? 30?
Gucken, ob es da einen Online-Rechner für gibt.
Ich bin zu pipiger, dass aus dem...
Ja, hier haben wir es.
Also wie viele Personen hast du?
Bei 25 Leuten ist es schon so,
dass die Chance, dass zwei Leute am gleichen Tag Geburtstag haben,
aus einer Gruppe von 25 Leuten,
ist 6-50%.
Und mein Beispiel mit 28 wären sogar 65%.
Also in Schulklassen,
in heutigen Schulklassen, die teilweise 35 Leute haben oder so,
ist es sogar eher unwahrscheinlich, dass du keinen Tag findest,
wo nicht mal zwei Leute am gleichen Tag Geburtstag haben.
Warum?
Das musst du dir in der Webseite mal dazu durchlesen,
oder in Wikipedia einfach dazu.
Also haben wir uns zu stärkeren Hashing-Funktionen wie SHA-2 eingestellt,
die ich in diesem Video benutze.
Mit unserer neuen Hashing-Technik unter der Brust
haschen wir alle Passwörter in unserem Database,
anstatt sie zu encryptieren,
um zu deiner Passwörter-Storage zu kommen.
Jetzt haben wir keine Schlüssel,
die die Passwörter-Tafel wie zuvor unbedingt öffnet,
was definitiv eine Verbesserung ist.
Trotzdem müssen wir über Dictionary-Attacke sprechen.
Wie es aussieht, benutzen viele Menschen extrem schwere Passwörter,
wie Passwort oder 123456.
Wenn ein Hacker Zugang zu deinem Database hat,
kann er einfach deine Hashing-Funktion auf Passwort
oder 123456 aufbauen,
um die Hashe zu finden
und dann alle Hashe, die in deinem Database passen, zu finden.
Voila, du hast die Passwörter der Menschen zerbrochen.
Dies nennt sich eine Dictionary-Attacke,
weil du die Diktionary-Attacke
Das hatten wir ja auch gerade schon.
...Hashing-Wörter, wie du gehst und siehst,
ob irgendeine von ihnen die Hashe passen.
Erinnere dich, dass es nicht möglich ist,
direkt eine Hashe in ein Passwort zurückzuwenden,
im Allgemeinen.
Trotzdem, weil der Hacker weiß,
dass die Hashe aus einem Passwort kam,
können sie mit ihrem Wissen der menschlichen Natur
die möglichen Gäste nachschneiden,
Außerdem können sie Liste der meisten
gemeinsamen Passwörter benutzen,
um ein riesiges Database von Hashen zu prägenieren.
All das, was sie tun müssen, ist,
ihr riesiges Database zu deinem Database zu vergleichen,
um Matchen zu finden.
Diese Databasen heißen Rainbow-Tables.
Wie können wir dagegen verteidigen?
Gehen wir zu B-Tier für eine Technik,
die gegen Rainbow-Tables schützt,
aber nicht gegen Dictionary-Attacke.
Es ist eine Technik namens Salting.
Wenn der User aufschreibt,
anstatt jedes Passwort direkt zu haschen,
nimmt er nicht nur das Passwort,
das er haschen will,
sondern packt auch
ein random Salt mit rein.
Das hier ist jetzt
mein random Salt.
Achso, da war ein Sonderzeichen
für die Shell drin.
Das ist jetzt
mein random Salt.
Da kommt ein anderer
Hasch-Buy raus.
Hat den riesigen Vorteil,
dass du
jetzt keine
vorberechenden Tabellen
mehr benutzen kannst.
Du kannst zwar nach wie vor
das mit einer Grafikkarte durchprobieren,
aber du kannst keine
vorberechenden Tabellen benutzen,
weil der random Hasch im Vorfeld ja nicht bekannt ist.
Wir können zuerst einen kurzen
random Salt-String generieren.
Danach schieben wir es zu dem String vor,
bevor wir den Hasch starten.
Danach storten wir den Salt.
Die Hasches geben ja auch keine
Informationen über den Input.
Die Hasches geben keine Informationen über den Input.
Du kannst dir nicht sicher sein,
dass das, was du in so einer Rainbow-Tabelle guckst,
wirklich das Passwort war,
was eingegeben wurde, um diesen
Hasch zu erzeugen.
Das weißt du nicht. Es gibt ja theoretisch unendlich viele
Inputs.
Es reicht dir aber, wenn du es
einfach findest,
wenn der gleiche Hasch rauskommt.
Kann man den Salt-Wert nicht herausfinden
mit Datenbankzugriff? Doch.
Der Salt-Wert ist
bekannt oftmals.
Der Salt-Wert ist nichts
Geheimes.
Der Salt-Wert ist
prinzipiell nichts Geheimes.
Du brauchst den Salt-Wert
sogar.
Du musst den Salt-Wert
sogar im Plaintext übertragen.
sogar übertragen können im Nachhinein.
Der Salt-Wert ist nur dafür da,
dass niemand hingehen kann
und petabyteweise
Tabellen erstellen kann
im Vorfeld.
Das ist der einzige Sinn von einem Salt.
Der Salt ist nicht dafür geheim zu sein.
Der Salt kann bekannt sein.
Der Salt ist nur dafür da, dass keiner
im Vorfeld vorberechnete Tabellen
anfertigen kann.
Weil der Salt ja random ist.
Und für jeden Fall individuell.
Das heißt, du kannst nicht
einfach eine Tabelle nehmen
für
einen Salt
und die mit dem anderen verwenden.
Das geht nicht.
Der Salt ist nur dafür da, um quasi
den Rechenaufwand zu erhöhen und den
Speicheraufwand und alles zu erhöhen.
Richtig, genau.
Der Salt ist nichts Geheimes.
Der Salt steht übrigens auch,
wenn ihr mal in
ETC
Shadow guckt,
steht da hier
example.etc.shadow
Das ist die Datei, wo
unter Linux die
Passwörter drin stehen.
Da seht ihr das.
Ich glaube, das hier ist der Salt.
Ich glaube, das ist der Salt.
Ihr könnt hier reingucken.
Das hier ist das Interessante.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
ich glaube, das ist der Hashing-Algorithmus
und das ist der Hash und das ist glaube ich
der Salt.
Ja, richtig.
Habe ich doch recht.
So ist das Format von der Linux-Passwort-Datei.
Das Erste ist der
Hashing-Algorithmus, der verwendet wird.
Das Zweite ist
der Salt.
Würde ich mal sagen, auch wenn es
jetzt hier nicht so wirklich drin ist.
Ah ja, doch, hier.
id salt hashed.
Also eins ist der Hashing-Algorithmus,
der verwendet wird.
Der muss bekannt sein. Der darf auch nicht geheim sein.
Weil der Kleine muss ja das Gleiche nochmal machen.
Der muss bekannt sein.
Der Salt kann auch
plaintext bekannt sein und dann hast du
den Hash dazu. Das ist hier quasi das gehashte
Passwort. Und dadurch, dass
dieser Salt random generiert
hier individuell für jeden User ist,
kannst du nicht einfach
eine
Riesencluster nehmen mit Grafikkarten
und drei Jahre lang Tabellen
generieren lassen, weil dir die Tabelle
nichts bringt, weil der Salt
für jeden Input anders ist.
Also Salt und Algorithmus
können ruhig bekannt sein. Das macht nix.
Das ist das, was ich euch auch gerade gezeigt habe
auf der Command-Seite.
Und man sieht auch, dass der Salt bekannt sein
muss, weil wenn ich
im Backend Salt plus Hash gespeichert habe,
also ich habe in meinem Backend in der Datenbank
stehen, User Max
benutzt Hash-Algorithmus
SHA256
mit diesem Salt und diesem Passwort
Hash. Wenn der Max
sich jetzt einloggen will, dann muss ich
dem Browser ja mitteilen,
ey, verwende mal SHA256
beim User
Passwort-Login
und mit diesem Salt
dann tippe ich das Passwort ein,
im Hintergrund nimmt mein Browser
den richtigen Hashing-Algorithmus, steckt den Salt
rein, überträgt den Hash
und dann kann ich gucken, aha, scheint wohl
zu stimmen.
Also der Salt, der muss sogar
Plaintext sein.
Das machst du im Browser.
Du hast den Backend, den Hash, den Salt und den Algorithmus
gespeichert und der Browser,
der ist die einzige Stelle, die das
Passwort im Plaintext jemals sieht.
Ja.
Du machst das,
du machst das kleinseitig.
Wie willst du es denn sonst machen?
Ich meine,
wie willst du es denn sonst...
Das würde nicht funktionieren.
Beim Klassischen,
wir machen...
einen
Basic-Auth oder so,
da ist es nicht so.
Bei Basic-Auth wird das Ganze
als Base64-Encoded
im Klartext übertragen.
Glücklicherweise
über TLS, aber das kannst du
knicken. Also Basic-Auth ist
nicht das beste Beispiel
für... Ja, wenn du es richtig machen willst,
würdest du das so machen. Und ich gehe mal davon aus,
dass die meisten Authentifizierungs-Libraries
das auch so machen. Aber du kannst es ja,
du musst es ja...
Aus der Logik heraus, musst du es
ja im Browser machen oder im Client machen,
weil dein Backend kennt das
Passwort ja gar nicht. Dein Backend kann das gar nicht
machen. Dein Backend oder die Datenbank
kennt ja wirklich nur den
Hash, den Algorithmus und den Salt.
Das heißt,
es muss ja an der Stelle passieren,
wo das Passwort im Klartext bekannt
ist. Und das ist beim User im Client.
Basic-Auth ist nicht unbedingt das beste
Beispiel dafür, weil da ist eh alles
vorbei. Da kannst du dich nur noch
drauf verlassen, dass das Ganze eben über
TLS geht und deswegen nichts passiert.
Kann man bestimmt auch machen.
Aber es ist halt blöd, wenn das Passwort
in irgendeiner Art und Weise überhaupt übertragen wird.
Ich meine, das kannst du auch machen.
Du kannst das Passwort übertragen,
im Backend hashen und gucken, ob der gespeicherte Hash rauskommt.
Das kannst du auch machen. Also,
ich habe sogar ein Beispiel für,
wie das unterschiedliche
Sachen, also
wie Services, die das unterschiedlich
gemacht haben.
Ich denke mal, viele werden es tatsächlich so machen,
zum Überprüfen. Du schickst das Passwort
im Plaintext rüber über TLS
und dann wird das dort gehashed
und überprüft.
Im Falle von ICQ früher war es umgedreht.
Da wurde das auf dem Client gemacht
und dementsprechend
konntest du dich mit dem
Hash
als Passwort quasi einloggen.
Also, wenn du
die Kommunikation mitgeschnitten hattest
damals mit ICQ
und den Hash wusstest,
dann konntest du den Hash übertragen
an ICQ und es hat dich einloggen lassen.
Das hat damals funktioniert.
Am schönsten ist es natürlich, wenn das Passwort nie
den Client verlassen muss.
Aber du hast schon recht, wahrscheinlich ist das
die verbreitete
Variante.
Da habe ich gerade nicht dran gedacht.
Da hast du, denke ich, recht.
Also bei ICQ damals
hatten sie es auf jeden Fall so gemacht,
den Passwort Hash einloggen, wenn du
das mitgeschnitten hast und dementsprechend geschickt hast.
Wenn die Webseite ohne
Javascript, dann hast du eh gelitten.
Dann bleibt dir ja
nur, was macht
ein Browser ohne Javascript standardmäßig?
Was kannst du da machen? Basic Auth?
Und wie heißt das andere?
Digest oder sowas?
Gedöns? Ich sag keine Ahnung.
Ich meine, heutzutage
ist das glücklicherweise halb so wild, weil das
alles über HTTPS, TLS geht.
Webassembly. Weiter.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das stimmt.
Du kannst halt nichts Vorberechnendes benutzen
brauchst halt im Zweifelsfall ewig.
Außer das Passwort ist kacke.
Ja, das ist gut.
Weil dann ist das für denjenigen, der das
mit einer GPU oder sonst wie
durchprobieren will, halt
kaum möglich.
Für den Einzelnen beim Login
ist das kein Problem.
Da ist es schnell genug.
Wenn du jetzt aber
Trilliarden durchprobieren willst,
dann hast du halt
keine Chance.
Du musst halt
auf jeden Fall
Trilliarden durchprobieren willst,
dann hast du gelitten.
Nein.
Das ist doch gerade
der Trick da dran.
Im Prinzip kann man das übertragen
auf nahezu, sagen wir mal, alle
guten
skriptografischen Sachen.
Du musst wissen,
du darfst wissen, wie es funktioniert,
aber
trotzdem, dass du weißt, wie es funktioniert,
darfst du trotzdem nicht an den
Plaintext kommen.
Nur durch das Wissen, wie der Algorithmus
funktioniert.
Du kannst wissen, wie es funktioniert.
Das ist im Prinzip ähnlich,
wir nehmen was ganz Simples.
Nehmen
eine Modulu-Operation.
Hau irgendwas Mod 5 durch.
Du kannst aus dem, was
da rauskommt,
keine wirklichen Rückschlüsse draus ziehen,
welche Zahl das Ergebnis
geliefert hat. Und du weißt,
was passiert. Es wird Mod 5 gemacht.
Aber nur, weil du weißt, dass Mod 5 gemacht wird,
wie Mod 5 funktioniert,
heißt das noch lange nicht, dass du rausbekommst, was als Input
reingeschoben wurde.
Du musst wissen können, wie es funktioniert, aber du darfst trotzdem
nicht damit weiterkommen.
Jetzt kommt
dieses High-IQ-Chat am Start.
das eine As funktionalmanaagent
The most interessting thing about this
is that the work factor
is exponential.
When you increase the work factor
by 1, de fundoection becomes times as
slow.
Hereis a graph by work effort
faster on my laptop.
De exponential increase is experience
is quite clear.
Most Folks Recommend
By the way Chat, bitterness
is a richer
copery
Ich Clabir
Das ist tatsächlich das, was Preserie vorhin geschrieben hat.
Ähm...
Äh...
Dass das eher zutrifft.
Also der Part...
Vergesst mal den Part, den ich euch erzählt hab,
über man sollte immer das kleinseitig machen,
weil, wenn ich mir so recht Gedanken drüber mache,
ist das eigentlich bescheuert, alles rein kleinseitig zu machen.
Auch wenn das ICQ früher so gemacht hat,
aber ICQ ist jetzt nicht unbedingt so das Aushängeschild für Sachen,
wie man machen sollte,
weil, wenn du rein kleinseitig haschst
und das dann überträgst, um zu gucken,
ob du authentifiziert werden kannst,
dann bedeutet das ja im Endeffekt,
dass du eigentlich das Passwort im Plaintext speicherst,
weil der Hash ja dann quasi das Passwort ist.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich sinnlos.
Also da hat er auf jeden Fall recht.
Genau, das hab ich mir auch gerade überlegt.
Also, ja, nee, das ist dann...
Vergesst mal den Part, den ich erzählt hab,
immer rein kleinseitig machen, ergibt auch keinen...
Eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Ja, machen wir weiter.
Naja, 2 ms ist gar nicht mal pro Hash.
Klingt jetzt wenig, aber ganz im Ernst,
wenn du Milliarden durchprobieren musst,
dann werden auch 2 ms relativ viel.
Ja gut.
...so that users can log in to your product
using an established authentication platform.
Not only is it more convenient for users...
Sign in with Aliexpress, Alibaba.
...you get to sleep better at night,
knowing that your system doesn't have any passwords at all in it.
That's all I have for today. Let's recap.
First, we looked at storing passwords in Plaintext,
which means anyone can easily access them.
Das war ein echt gutes Zusammenfassungsvideo.
Excellent.
Jetzt noch das Passkey-Video dranhängen.
Nee.
Jetzt?
Wisst ihr, was ich jetzt mache?
Nein, nicht Nudeln mit Lachs.
Nudeln mit Bolognese, korrekt.
Was ist eigentlich, Chatgy?
Was ist eigentlich aus dem Router geworden?
Hab ich das irgendwie überlesen?
Da kam gar nichts mehr, oder?
Wie hieß er denn?
Ähm...
Ah, hast gepackt!
Nice.
Und was war's? Ich hab das gar nicht gelesen.
Soweit geht mein Chat nicht zurück.
Der Reset hat's gefixt. Okay, done.
Siehste?
Freifahrt-Remote-Chat-Support hat's geregelt.
Abrechnung kommt.
Alles klar, wir sehen uns, Leute.
Ich geh jetzt futtern.
Bis denn. See you.